Yes.
All right.
We're live.
Hey,
what's up man?
How are you?
I'm well,
I'm here with Tovar surreally.
He's got his pen and his notebook out
like he's about to take notes.
Uh,
author of the mindful carnivore boy,
you went to an unusual path,
man.
And this is one of the reasons why I
really wanted to talk to you.
A,
I've read some of your stuff and I've
seen some interviews with you online.
Obviously a very intelligent,
very thoughtful guy.
He started out a Vegan and became a
hunter.
Boy,
that's,
that's a tricky path and it had to be a
fraught with peril,
right?
I mean,
how much grief did you take for that?
First of all?
You know,
not as much as I kind of anticipate
really.
I mean,
that gives you live in Vermont,
but you know,
they could be part of it,
you know,
they can't get to you up there and it's,
and it's a funny blend.
The cultures there.
Uh,
I mean,
I didn't become vegetarian until I was
like 20,
so I spent basically 20 to 30 as
vegetarian,
mostly Vegan that whole time.
And so then in my early thirties,
I made this kind of bizarre transitioned
into,
into being a hunter.
Uh,
and I wondered how friends,
not so much family,
cause I had one uncle who,
who was a hunter and was well respected
but you know,
but friends,
you know,
I wondered,
what,
what was that going to be like?
And uh,
uh,
there were some,
you know,
some occasionally odd moments with,
with friends or neighbors,
but not as much as you might expect.
What was it that made you switch over?
Like what was there a moment?
Was it a realization?
Was it an accumulation of information?
Like what was it?
I mean,
the switch to being vegetarian had a lot
to do with ethics and animal welfare and
compassion and then it became other
issues,
environmental,
you know,
kinds of things.
The switchback,
um,
the first step really was starting to
realize that my diet,
whatever I was eating was connected to
all kinds of things that I didn't
realize,
you know,
control of deer in soybean fields to
make tofu.
I mean,
yeah,
you know,
the control is a nice way.
It is.
It's a gentle,
it's a gentle word,
right?
Um,
and just the impact of agriculture on
the landscape as a whole.
Talk About Wildlife Habitat disappearing
in a hurry,
you know,
um,
and even the local organic farmer down
the road where we,
you know,
go get organic strawberries,
when there's enough crop damage,
he calls a friend and they shoot a deer
or their smoke bomb in the woodchucks
all the time.
And so there are all kinds of impacts
that I realized my diet was having,
even though I wasn't eating animals,
you know,
indirectly that didn't change my diet,
that just sort of soften these very
black and white hard edges that I had
drawn in my,
these ethical
lines.
Right.
The shift to actually eating something
different had more to do with
nutritional needs in the longterm.
And once I started eating some yogurt,
which is a big radical step,
if you've been Vegan for 10 years,
you know,
eating a bowl of yogurt is a big deal.
Or if you,
you know,
eggs and fish and chicken.
Once I did that,
I said I'm going to go back to fishing,
which it did as a kid.
And then I,
I live in a rural area,
you know,
I'm in the woods practically and I look
around was like,
hmm,
if I'm going to get protein,
animal protein,
there's some of that running around here
in the woods and it's still part of the
culture there where I live in Vermont,
you know,
hunting is still alive as part of the
culture.
So it started to sort of sneak up on me
as his idea to,
to get into hunting.
Wow.
Well
the eggs are an easy one because nobody
has to get hurt.
Like eating eggs is so easy if you,
especially I have my own chicken,
so it's just,
hey girls,
what's going on?
Take the eggs.
No one gets hurt,
everything's fine.
And um,
that seems to me to be the easiest and
most ethical way.
If you just want to get some animal
protein in your body,
that one really is no one,
no one's getting hurt.
Those things I didn't,
you know,
this is so embarrassing,
but I didn't even know.
I think I was in my late thirties,
early forties when I found out that
chicken eggs couldn't become a chicken
because a,
they weren't fertilized by a rooster.
Like this is how stupid I was or more,
more really removed from us.
Any farming or any idea of farming.
I just a from my,
in my stupid mine,
I just had this idea that,
and then I,
I've had a thing,
oh yeah,
of course there's still rooster and how,
wait a minute,
why are they laying eggs every day?
Like what the Hell is going on?
And I don't understand that part of it,
but um,
it's so easy to just get eggs from
chickens.
I mean,
as long as you're feeding the chicken,
chicken's exist off of so many different
things.
They cleaned your garden,
they run around there.
They mostly bugs and grass and chicken
in know healthy chicken food.
But once you decide you're going to pull
the trigger on a deer,
things get real.
That's a totally different experience.
Cause there's this one guy who's this
healthy ethical Vegan who's walking
around looking at the deer like hello
friend.
And the next day,
you know,
you're elbows deep in that deer pulling
out its guts,
hanging it up in a barn and taking the
skin off of it.
That's exactly right.
And it took me a few years from when I
started hunting too and I was learning
through email to my uncle and reading
articles and poking around in the woods
and there was a slow learning process
and there aren't tons of deer running
around Vermont.
There are some,
but I was not really,
no.
Back in the back in the sixties and
seventies,
we had all this young growth forest,
you know,
all these,
these uh,
farm fields that were coming back into
forest and there were a ton of deer.
It was really rich habitat for deer.
Now it's a much more mature forest.
And so the numbers have,
have really dropped down predators up
there where they have coyotes and bear.
But you know,
nothing that is really a good Predator
on adult dear.
Um,
so
I was trying to on but unsuccessful for
several years.
And in retrospect,
I'm really glad because I don't think I
was ready for that experience.
So you were saying,
I'm going to go hunting,
but you weren't getting anything,
so you're trying to find the deer.
So it was more like some deer by hiking
with a backpack that has a gun in it.
Yeah,
I mean,
I did a little bit of small game
hunting.
I took a,
you know,
a snowshoe Hare,
too small,
you know,
but a deer is a different experience.
You know,
something,
it's a mammal,
but something that big to,
um,
and you know,
something that beautiful.
I mean,
they're,
they're stunning animals.
And so when it finally happened a few
years in,
it was a total shock.
The actual experience,
even though I'd seen someone else with a
deer,
they had just killed.
And I helped my uncle,
but doing it yourself,
different games.
And how did you prepare for this?
Did you take courses?
Did you train yourself?
How to shoot?
Did you already know how to shoot?
I had shot a bit as a kid.
I'd been around.
Firearms are up to you if,
sure.
Sure.
Um,
you know,
I'd been around firearms a little bit as
a kid.
I had never shot a deer rifle,
you know,
centerfire rifle.
So that was new.
Um,
but yeah,
it was learning from books,
articles,
my uncle,
a lot of emails back and forth.
You know,
I was totally clueless.
about firearms,
about deere,
about everything.
It was a starting from ground zero and
so slow.
It was slow.
That's a real commitment.
Like especially if you're doing it
essentially by herself,
you know,
to,
to decide to really get involved in
quote unquote gun culture and uh,
understand what kind of round you need a
rifle you need.
What's the best kind of rifle was the
best way to pull the trigger.
How do you,
how do you keep yourself from jerking or
punching the trigger and you know,
there's a lot of practice involved.
Oh yeah,
there is,
there's a ton to learn and I think
that's one of the interesting things
with what I call adult onset hunters.
Those of us who come to it later in
life,
it sounds like diabetes,
um,
onset hunters that we don't know a
million things that those people who
grew up doing it take for granted about
the woods,
about firearms,
about all kinds of things.
And they forgot they even learned them
cause they,
you know,
they learned it when they were 10 or 15.
Uh,
and we don't know any of that.
We've lived,
maybe
we've spent some time in the woods,
maybe we know something about fishing
or,
but we don't know that whole world.
So it's a challenge without a mentor.
So for me,
my uncle was really helpful.
Um,
but having a mentor is really key I
think for folks who come to it later in
life.
Yeah.
It's so much so that I was thinking that
there's gotta be some way to start a
program that teaches people the ethics
of it.
And boy,
it's,
it's so hard to do because you're
talking about something that reasonably
should take a long time before you
actually,
I think the way you did it,
taking a long time before you actually
shoot a deer,
it's probably the way to go.
I got a crazy crash course from Steven
Rinella,
right?
Um,
where I did his television show.
I shot literally a couple times at a
piece of paper and I'm not bullshitting.
We set up a target,
put it on like a,
a patch of dirt and a shot a couple of
times where he's explaining how you have
to squeeze,
you can't jerk it.
You have to squeeze and a,
then next thing you know,
I'm shooting a deer like five days later
or whatever it was.
It was a very strange,
and it took me a while to sort of let
all the information set in and then get
my skills up to like,
I pulled it off the first time,
but I easily could have fucked up.
I easily could a wounded animal.
I,
you know,
I really wasn't ready,
um,
to get someone,
especially someone with a fulltime job,
someone with a family obligations to get
them somehow another set up,
some sort of a course that allows them
to learn how to do that.
Right.
Well,
there's demand for it.
And yes,
there are a bunch of states that are
doing it.
They're like Wisconsin,
Minnesota,
have really good programs,
adult learn to hunt programs and they do
it over the course of like six or nine
months.
You have an intro workshop usually at
the local food co op or something.
It recruit people there and then they
end up,
um,
having these weekend sessions throughout
the course of the year.
And it culminates with a sort of a
mentor at hunt on public land in,
um,
in Wisconsin or Minnesota or other
states that have similar programs.
But there's enough demand that there are
private courses.
I mean,
there's work we can workshops being
offered by folks I know not associated
with the state program at all,
just teaching people because they didn't
learn.
And there's a huge demand,
I think,
not just for hunting,
but people want these old skills,
you know,
hands on,
whether it's how to physically build
something out of wood or had a can your
own food or how to,
you know,
hunt and butcher a deer and there's an
interest in that sort of do it yourself.
Uh,
quote unquote primitive or just basic
self-reliant skills.
Yeah.
I mean,
even if you're not thinking about being
a prepper,
if you're not,
you know,
if you're not getting ready for the end
of the world,
it's still,
it's a fascinating thing to learn how to
take care of yourself and learn how to
get your own food from the actual
wilderness.
Right?
Or even or from the garden.
I mean,
just that hands on experience.
I direct experience is really different
from seeking sitting in a cubicle,
getting paid,
and then going and buying food at the
grocery store.
You know,
the,
the uh,
author Richard Nelson,
who's written great books about deer and
all kinds of things.
Um,
he lives up in Alaska and he calls the,
uh,
the supermarket an agency,
an agent of our forgetfulness,
and we forget where things come from if
we don't live on a farm,
if we didn't grow up doing that kind of
thing.
Yeah.
I think that's an issue that a lot of
people who have paid attention to all
the different videos that have been
released from these factory farms that
are horrific and they try to figure out,
well,
what is a way to get around this?
What's,
there's gotta be a way to get around
this.
And the most ethical way,
I think,
and a lot of people think is if it's
possible to hunt it yourself because
then you're getting an animal that was
never caged up.
It was a wild animal.
And in one brief moment,
it's life ends.
And realistically that life was probably
on its way out anyway.
If you're shooting a mature deer,
he shooting something that's six years
old,
five years old.
It's amazing that deer live that long in
the first place.
Yeah.
Most wild animals are prey.
You know,
most prey animals and even most
predators in fact,
you know,
die when they're pups basically.
I mean,
the mortality rate is incredibly high.
Yeah.
I mean,
even the mortality rate for bears is
insanely high.
And the Predator of bears is bears,
you know,
there's a bear's kill half of all the
moose calves and um,
and deer Fonz,
like half of them that get born get
killed by bears or coyotes or wolves or
anything.
So to get something that's five years
old,
you are,
you essentially stepping in just before
nature did.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
I don't know enough about all the
ecology and biology of all these species
to speak authoritatively on that side of
it,
but the idea of it being an ethical
alternative make sense to a lot of
people.
I think it resonates.
The people that I've interviewed who are
adult onset hunter is,
you know,
and from my own experience,
that's a pretty common theme.
There's an ethical drive involved,
whether it's practical for a huge
portion of the population to really do
that is a different,
you know,
statistical question.
It's just not,
but,
uh,
you know,
it's also not practical for the United
States to feed every country in the
world.
It's not practical for everyone to exist
off all the crops grown in England.
It's not private.
There's a lot of things that aren't
practical.
Exactly.
Not that those things do exist,
but what you can do as a human,
you can still today in the United States
and still learn how to hunt,
hunt,
and get all your food from that.
It is still possible.
It might not be possible for everybody
in the country to do it,
but guess what?
Everyone in the country is not going to
do in anyway.
It's like,
no.
You know,
like saying,
is it possible to write a book?
Yes.
It is.
Guess how few fucking people write
books.
You wrote a book.
How many people write books?
I mean,
you could go all day without meeting
anybody who's ever written a book.
You know,
um,
this book that you wrote,
the mindful carnivore,
um,
I don't think I've ever even seen a book
written
by a guy who started off as a vegetarian
and a Vegan and was compelled to,
uh,
to become a hunter.
You know,
it seems when I first got into the idea
of writing a book,
which seemed crazy and still in
retrospect seems kind of crazy.
Um,
but when I started even writing a couple
essays about that,
about going from being a Vegan and
vegetarian to being a hunter,
I thought this is bizarre.
I don't know what people are going to
make of this.
Over time I've met more and more people
who have actually had a pretty similar
experience,
other vegetarians who became hunters.
And there's a,
there's a logic to it.
Like if you were that concerned about
animals that you decided to be
vegetarian or Vegan and then you changed
your diet,
animals are still a pretty serious issue
for you unless you just abandoned your
entire philosophy and left out the door.
If you still have those basic values and
you still take animal welfare and
environmental conservation and these
sorts of issues,
seriously,
then
there's a interest in engaging directly,
like confronting it,
right.
Instead of just saying,
oh well just go to the supermarket now
and just buy some ground chuck.
Right?
So for those of us who still have animal
ethics and welfare in mind,
when we make that transition out of
being vegetarian,
there's a,
there's a way to confront it.
You know,
I know some folks who were vegetarian,
young couple,
um,
and when their diet changed,
they decided they're going to raise it
on animals instead of hunt started
raising chickens and
now they do it full time.
The chicken farmers,
chicken cows,
rabbits,
they run a,
a CSA community supported agriculture.
They supply meat to these two x
Vegetarians,
supply meat to this,
you know,
whole area up where we live.
So
they wanted to confront it directly.
It's just,
you know,
the same kind of thing.
They go,
if we're going to do this,
we're going to do it ourselves.
Now you say your diet changed,
like,
like it used to be spraying and now it's
summer.
Right now mean what does,
what does that mean you're diet changed
and why did you die change?
What was the reason?
Yeah,
I mean for me it was that my health was
iffy.
You know,
I wasn't in,
you know,
on death's door,
but my immune system was kind of
depressed and that sort of thing.
And several people,
including my wife and my doctor said,
you know,
maybe this is part of the picture,
think about your diet and start adding
some other things in.
And so when I started to add in some
eggs,
yogurt,
some local chicken,
that kind of thing,
it did change.
It really did.
So for me it was a,
it was a nutrition issue.
But is it possible that you just weren't
doing veganism correctly?
That's always the question,
you know,
that's always the question.
Um,
could I have done some things
differently?
Possibly.
What will you,
will you eating for your protein?
Well,
I mean,
I was eating plenty of what they used to
call sort of mixed,
you know,
you know rice and beans and veggies and
fruit and,
but even on very strict Vegan websites,
they'll say,
you know,
you need to take b12 something right
there.
There's things that are really hard to
get if you're not eating any animal.
Well,
some people deny that.
That's a really fascinating conversation
I've had with a friend of mine who's a
Vegan who says,
you know,
you really need very little b12 and you
can get plenty of b 12 from your diet.
I'm like,
boy,
that's um,
that's controversial.
Like for you to be real confident about
that.
I'm not,
I'm not sure that's necessarily correct
because I've seen both really strong
statements on both sides.
Really strong statements that you
definitely can't get it from your diet
and really strong statements that you
can and I don't know who to believe.
Yeah.
I mean I'm known nutrition expert
either,
but it's primarily from animals though,
be 12 correct.
As I understand,
I mean flax seeds and there are ways to
think you can get it,
but whether it's that easy to assimilate
into your body and actually use,
I think it depends on the source and you
know,
there's a huge difference.
It traditionally,
as I understand it,
between a Vegan diet and the vegetarian
diet,
if you're eating some eggs or reading
some,
some dairy,
that's a different ballgame.
We have cultures and traditions of
vegetarianism around the world that have
sustained themselves.
I don't know of any communities and
cultures or traditions around the world
where they've been Vegan for generation
after generation.
I don't think,
I don't think it exists.
Isn't it possible though that it
requires more education,
more understanding about what the
nutritional requirements are like as far
as like mixing your proteins and making
sure,
cause we had some guys on from the
documentary cowspiracy and we talked
about,
and I really wish I'd read a little bit
more of a,
the arguments against what they were
saying before I had him on because uh,
one of the things we talked about is
like complete proteins and a complete
amino acid profiles.
They will,
there's very few complete proteins and
plant form.
It's very few.
And if you're getting like,
if you're trying to get all your protein
from Broccoli,
Jesus Christ,
you've got to eat like pounds of the
stuff in order to like,
and so I don't think it's one of the
things it becomes with a lot of people,
it becomes almost like you're talking
about their deity.
It's almost like a religious argument
because they don't want to be objective
about it in any one exception to that is
rich roll rituals,
very objective.
And uh,
I don't know if you know who he is,
he's a another name.
But again,
endurance athlete,
right?
Very good guy and has a great podcast
and he's been a guest on the podcast a
couple of times here.
Really cool guy.
But he's,
he's very non dogmatic and also,
uh,
not a judgemental guys.
No,
he's not.
he's not preaching.
Um,
but for a lot of them they just don't
want to admit the difficulty in getting
complete sources of protein.
And,
and then there's a few Vegan
bodybuilders.
These are,
these people are hilarious.
You find out they're doing steroids.
Like Dick Dickhead.
Yeah,
no,
I don't think so.
But like Vegan bodybuilding is,
it's is fraud.
It's fucking infested with people that
are doing steroids that aren't being
honest about it,
that are getting gigantic that or you
know,
eating Vegan food and like Vegan power
and they're,
they're flexing,
you know,
meanwhile they've got fucking synthetic
testosterone,
which by the way,
it's made with yams.
You can make synthetic testosterone
isn't Mexican wild yams.
Yeah.
And in a way,
but it's,
it's just hilarious.
And they're attributing all this,
fucking scientists have made your body
man,
right.
Scientists in a weight room.
But you know,
there's,
you know,
that's neither here nor there,
but I think it's,
for some people it's,
it is very difficult if you're,
if you're going to be Vegan to get
everything your body requires.
You know,
you know who travis barker is the
drummer from blink one eight two really
cool guy,
got in a plane crash and a was burned
really badly.
He had a bunch of skin graphs and stuff
and uh,
it wasn't taking until he ditched his
Vegan Diet.
Who's having a real hard time healing?
And I hear things like that.
I go,
man,
what is going on?
Because how come some people can tell me
that they're doing so well,
they heal quicker,
they recover quicker on a Vegan Diet,
they feel better on a Vegan Diet.
And then other people are telling me,
you know,
it's just their body just wasn't healing
correctly.
Their immune system was floundering like
what's going on?
And I think part of it is probably that
we have,
our bodies are different.
We have somewhat,
I mean we're the same species,
we have basic profile,
but we have all kinds of end of the more
science progressed is looking at,
you know,
our microflora inside our bodies.
I mean we're all really different.
So it may be that we processed and need
things in different ways and there's,
for many people,
I think there's a real change in over
time.
So in a short period of time,
if you've been eating a really crappy
diet full of tons of fried food and then
you start eating a whole foods vegan
diet,
Lo and behold,
you're going to feel better,
right?
Because you're suddenly eating in
general,
healthier,
cleaner food.
Um,
after 10,
20 years for many people,
I think there are depletions and
consequences in the body of being strict
Vegan for all,
you know,
for that long period of time.
Did you attempt to talk to a
nutritionist and find out like are there
any foods that I should like keen
war things on hemp protein,
things that I need to mix in that or
pleat proteins?
I didn't really,
you know,
by that point because my,
those sort of black and white lines I
had drawn,
it was really rigid ethical ideas,
that sort of deity concept that I had in
a way and it's attachment to my identity
that had started to blur and loosened
enough.
It was like,
you know,
I live in this world,
not in some fantasy world.
I live here and even the local farmer
who grows our strawberries is smoke
Wyoming woodchucks and shooting deer and
he's eating venison and like I'm part of
this interconnected system,
you know,
this natural community of all kinds of
creatures,
plants,
animals.
I'm not separate from that.
And why do I,
why am I so fixated have I been for,
you know,
this past decade so fixated on
separating myself from this world that I
actually inhabit?
I think not,
I'm not saying that's true for all
vegetarians.
They're all vegans by any means.
But for me there was in a sense a
desire to live in this ideal
philosophical world,
not in this like physical,
natural world that I actually inhabit.
I'm actually an animal that inhabits
this place.
I have a footprint here,
you know,
not just my carbon footprint comes with
the car.
I drive,
whatever,
but I have a physical footprint no
matter what I eat.
Right?
I'm impacting.
It's a whole network of connections,
you know,
through agriculture and all kinds of
ways.
I'm not separate from this.
Why don't I actually
eat
more of the kinds of foods that human
beings have been eating forever that we
evolved on,
you know?
And so I just start to experiment with
it and see both how it felt physically,
but also sort of emotionally,
ethically,
spiritually,
philosophically.
How did it feel to start to,
to do that?
And it was strange.
I mean,
it was a kind of a bizarre experience to
start to eat,
especially to start eating meat again.
It was weird,
even before I was hunting,
I can only imagine.
I think what's going on is all connected
to what your friend calls the supermart.
What did you call an agent of
forgetfulness?
Yeah.
I think it's connected to that in that
we are so disconnected from our food
that even people that are are vegans,
that you know,
they think that they're causing no harm
because they just eat plants.
If you're eating commercial grain,
you're,
you're a part of a massive widescale
death.
In fact,
it's probably,
there's probably more dead animals per
acre in if you're getting commercial
grain than almost anything when they,
when they grind up that grain to chew it
up and to turn it into like if you have
a corn wheat and they chop
all that stuff down,
those combines are indiscriminate.
They kill everything,
right?
I mean they've,
they've made some improvements in that,
you know,
over the decades.
But sure.
Small mammals,
birds,
and then there's also just the fact that
when you create something like that,
whatever natural wildlife would have
been there has been completely removed
and you turned it into this weird new
thing where it's a monoculture,
right,
where you're just growing soybeans or
you're just growing whatever,
whatever the hell it is.
I think that by not participating in it,
and by not participating in any aspect
of the gathering of the food,
you get this detachment from it and you
say,
you know,
hey,
I can remove myself from any cruelty.
And he had ethical concerns by just
establishing a cruelty free Vegan Diet.
Right.
And it becomes a lot easier to,
to think in those black and white terms,
either not there,
good,
bad,
you know,
it's very easy to separate that because
you don't experience it and realize,
oh,
plants eat animals,
animals eat animals,
then animals die and plants eat film.
It's all this whole system that
everything including us as part of,
yeah.
And we as a culture,
as a society for,
for,
you know,
decades,
centuries have been various ways
separating ourselves from that through
industrialization,
um,
through,
you know,
just our ideas.
Again,
this is culturally specific.
Not every culture in the world thinks
this way,
but we do think of ourselves as very
separate.
And,
uh,
there's,
environmental philosopher,
uh,
who,
who's now passed on,
but,
uh,
her name was val plumwood.
She was in Australia and she talked
about this and she talked about how even
our practices around and our ideas
around our own life and death as humans
and how we bury ourselves in these
concrete boxes to sort of keep ourselves
from decomposing supposedly,
right.
I said like protect ourselves from death
and the idea of us being part of that
world in a physical way.
We actually,
you know,
ending up being food eventually she
thinks that we,
and I think,
I think she's right,
that we reject that as a culture.
We just,
we don't have room for that.
Right.
Well that's one of the things what we do
to our bodies we embalm than when we
sort of remove ourselves permanently
from the cycle,
which is really kind of fucked up.
Have some formaldehyde buddy.
I'm like,
why do we,
do we really need to stare at our dead
bodies?
Like sitting with perfect clothing on
and you know,
you're not dead.
It's just so fucked up that we,
I've only seen it a couple times,
but I remember when it was my
grandfather and now I was really close
to my grandfather.
So when I went to his funeral and I saw
him sitting there in that box,
and I realize how bizarre it was,
her,
first of all,
he's not there.
I'm like,
this is a shell does not my grandpa,
he's gone like this is some strange
thing.
And like they've pumped him full of all
this stuff so he doesn't stink because
the stinking is natural.
It's like that's what supposed to happen
to a person.
You were supposed to put them in the
ground and the bacteria eats them.
You fertilize the soil and make it
better for everything around.
Right.
And when we don't do that,
what do we do?
We burn ourselves to turn ourselves into
powder.
Right till fucking totally useless.
We're real weird with how we treat our
bodies and the concept of death.
Yeah.
It's totally true.
One of the things that I love to do with
people that have,
uh,
too much of a Disney view of animals and
like,
again,
you know,
I can't believe that you would hunt.
I can't believe you would kill deer.
Do you know that deer eat birds and
they'll go,
what?
Yeah.
Deer eat birds.
They just tell me a bizarre a,
I've seen a couple of those videos.
I mean probably pretty darn rare,
but they chase them.
They've been known to very,
again very rare,
but they've been known to like in the
shallows like whack fish and eat pretty
unusual behavior.
Most of the time they can't pull it off,
but when they can pull it,
it's like dear are designed essentially
to graze.
It's real simple.
They're the way they are,
but they'll take their food any way they
can get it and that is really hard for
people to believe like cows as well.
Like cows eat ground nesting birds all
the time.
There's videos of cows doing it and when
you show that to people,
they're like,
what the fuck is going on?
But maybe what we're doing is we're
ruining the earth so much that the
animals themselves are killing each
other and hating it and they've always
done this.
They just don't do it a lot because
they're just not designed for it.
And there's plenty of vegetation where
the deer live,
especially like white tail deer who live
primarily around agriculture.
They were around so much vegetation,
so much food that the last thing do you
have to worry about?
Most of the time it's starving to death
when they were around like farmlands and
stuff like that.
I mean up our way in the north and in,
in some other parts of,
of you know,
know the new s and up into Canada where
you get into mostly forested areas and
you get over populations of deer.
They wipe out their winter habitat if
they have too many deer and they're
starvation time is winter right there
because of the deep snow.
They're compressed into tiny,
tiny fractions of their usual usual
range.
And they can in fact,
you know,
starve to death and in vast numbers,
but around agriculture and more moderate
climates.
Yeah.
They've got no shortage of food.
And deer.
It's really interesting how they're set
up.
It's a,
it's almost like a,
it's making sure that they don't last
through when they're the older strong,
mature bucks cause a mature buck will go
from the prime of its life to on death's
door within a couple months during the
Rut.
And it's really crazy.
They drive them.
So they use all their fat reserves and
burn it,
and they're doing it right when the
winter's coming.
Right.
And sometimes bad design,
it's terrible,
but it's almost like it's on purpose
because for people who aren't aware of
the process,
what happens is the deer will eat all
throughout
the summer.
Uh,
the,
you know,
they'll,
they'll fatten up,
they look great,
their antlers grow.
And uh,
as soon as the air starts getting crisp
around the fall,
they get ready to party.
Um,
the velvet falls off their antlers,
their antlers start to get hard.
Um,
and then the females go into heat and
then the party starts and they just run
around running for so long that they
sometimes forget to eat.
They burn off all their fat and they get
skinny and scrawny,
and then by the end of it,
it's cold.
And when it's cold,
that's when they die.
So they'll go from being like a stud,
primary their life dear to being a dead,
starving to death,
frozen to death,
deer within a couple of months.
It's a really weird,
and especially in,
you know,
in those kinds of harsh climates where
it's,
where it is cold,
deep snow,
limited food,
it can be really risky.
Yeah.
Like the like mule deer in particular,
right.
Because,
um,
I know,
I don't know,
I know what happens to white tails but
may happen with mule deer as much or
more.
Well,
it's just a nature almost has like these
fail safe system set up to make sure
that these mature bucks only have their
time in the sun for so long.
You know,
you get your party on all the,
all the females love Ya,
you're having a great time,
you father a lot of offspring and then
that's a wrap.
Yeah.
One of the things that I find
fascinating is that
different groups,
vegetarians,
hunters and others who often seem
diametrically opposed on,
on an issue like hunting,
um,
often are motivated by really similar
values.
I mean,
a concern for environmental
conservation,
a concern for even animal welfare.
I mean in hunting,
the ethic of the clean kill,
the,
the idea that you should only shoot
wants and it should be virtually
instantaneous.
You know,
and even the concern that you express
your,
Gee,
I got this crash course so fast,
I could have wounded an animal.
You know,
the concern about wounding an animal is
a concern about,
you know,
not causing suffering,
undue suffering,
not,
um,
violating essentially an animal welfare
ethic.
Right.
Um,
and that
there's such different languages being
spoken often by,
you know,
folks who are on a sort of an animal
rights or animal welfare activist side
and folks who are on sort of a hunting
and hunting conservation activist side
of things.
And,
and often they're speaking very
different languages and don't realize
that they have some things in common.
Uh,
you had,
uh,
back at the beginning of January,
you had,
is it filled?
Demars the guy with the greenland.
Greenland,
exactly.
Yeah.
So he's an animal rights activists doing
really important work related to,
you know,
orcas and other captive captive animals.
Um,
and he has a real respect for and gets
where you're coming from in your
interest in hunting.
Yeah.
You know,
and so there are people who do get it
across those,
you know,
those,
he's different.
First of all,
I'm pretty sure he eats meat.
Didn't he say he eats meat?
I think he may be,
but also on top of that,
he's,
we're talking about marine mammals that
are super intelligent and I have,
I have a deep appreciation and respect
for those things.
And I think they're basically like water
people.
I really do.
I just think they don't fingers,
they don't have a language that we can
really accurately interpret.
But when you pay attention to Helen,
insanely smart dolphins and orchids are,
to me,
locking them up is akin to a slavery.
It's almost like slavery.
It's insanity.
I just despise it.
I think it's sick.
It costs me money because a,
there's the best comedy room in Vegas is
in the Mirage and I won't work it.
I've done it in the past and then I was
told that the Mirage has dolphins and I
was like,
ah,
fuck man,
I can't work there.
I just can't.
I can't,
I can't do comedy.
I can't have a fucking,
he,
he and Aha show a above a slave ship.
And that's what it feels like.
Sure.
But that idea that there are water
people.
Yeah.
It's interesting because in many
traditional hunting societies,
they speak of animals as people you
know,
and have them as,
and even deer,
you know,
they have,
if a society,
it's not the same say as a dolphin pod
or a wolf pack,
it's a different,
but they know those animals really
intimately as a species and sometimes
even as individuals,
but the language,
the idea of them as,
as other people,
as,
as animal people.
And yet they're hunting cultures,
you know,
and so they're,
they're taking lives.
Uh,
but they're also have a deep respect.
It's not that Obo will kill the ones we
don't respect.
What were the kill the ones that are
kind of ugly.
But the ones that we respect are the
ones that are beautiful.
We won't touch.
That's not it.
That's not how they're thinking about
it.
Yeah.
And we often do my agent,
I have an agent and I love her to death.
She's awesome.
But she loves animals.
She's vegetarian,
she loves animals.
But she doesn't mind if I hunt wild
pigs.
Cause there's disgusting,
ugly and disgusting was art.
There's this arbitrary aesthetic that,
that some people will say,
well,
you know,
it's an ugly kind of fish or it's an
ugly kind of mammal where any kind of
fish really,
there's very few people give a fuck if
you kill a fish,
they just really don't care.
Right.
It's,
and it's a different experience.
Yeah.
Emotionally.
It's totally different and it is,
but it is,
we,
it is weird and moving.
I mean,
oh,
here's a tangible sense of a loss of
life.
That was,
I was big into fishing when I was a kid,
when I was probably like,
um,
I guess I moved to Boston when I was 13.
That's when I really got into fishing
and I used to fish every day.
I used to live in this place called
Jamaica plain and they had this lake,
they're called Jamaica pond and uh,
they had bass and trout and I loved it.
I'd go there every day and I'd catch
fish there all the time.
And whenever I killed one and 82,
I always felt weird.
Like I just killed some.
Right.
I mean,
that was the experience that actually
made me decide to be vegetarian.
I fished all my childhood growing up.
Loved it.
My,
uh,
fishing mentor was a guy from Boston who
grew up in the bronx and he was a,
he was a furniture builder in Boston.
And he come up and visit us in southern
New Hampshire and we'd,
you know,
we'd fish all the time,
but when I was 20,
I had been thinking a lot about,
you know,
what kind of life I wanted to leave,
what my values,
and I went fishing and I caught this
trout and I killed it.
And I was like,
I didn't have to do that.
Right.
I didn't have to kill that.
I could have had,
you know,
rice and veggies or whatever.
Well,
that I didn't have to.
It was one of the big arguments that
people even say against hunting,
even if they eat meat,
you can go to the supermarket.
You don't have to kill it.
Right.
It's the voluntary participation that
for some people is hard to fathom.
Now,
do you get all your meat from hunting
all my red meat?
If we have red meat,
I mean we'll buy local chicken,
you know?
Um,
but if we happen to have red meat in the
house,
it's because I was lucky the previous
November and you won't go to these
people that,
you know,
that raise chickens and cows and
I could,
and there's just,
there's no really good rational argument
for it.
I just never got back into the habit of
like buying beef.
Right,
right,
right.
Ecologically and ethically,
it probably makes pretty good sense.
You know,
and I have,
I don't have a big argument against it.
I just never got into that,
back into that habit.
Um,
so the experience of taking a deer is so
profoundly different,
obviously from going to the grocery
store or even go to a farmer,
you know,
um,
and having that is so valuable to me.
Um,
and it's such a reminder,
you know,
talk about the opposite of the
supermarket as an agent of
forgetfulness.
You know,
when you take a package of innocent or
the freezer and you remembered that deer
that you killed,
I mean,
there's no forgetting where that comes
from.
Oh yeah,
no,
it's always present.
Yeah.
It's indescribable to someone who hasn't
experienced it.
It's very,
very difficult to,
uh,
to even imagine what it's like because
there's some,
I mean,
I hate to use the word spiritual because
it just gets so beaten down and overused
and watered down.
But there is a weird spiritual
connection between your meat or a
tangible,
um,
energy.
It's connected to the experience that
you had,
the meat that you're eating,
the knowledge that you were the one who
took the life of the knowledge.
It was a life,
it was a living being and now it's food
on your plate and you're watching your
family eat it.
When you're having friends that come
over and eat it.
It's,
it's,
I just think that cities are something
really unusual and alien and a,
I think human beings have created them
out of convenience and it's wonderful
and it's allowed us to gather
information and to create these
incredible places where you can just
group together millions and millions of
people and you just ship all the food
in.
But in doing so,
we've created this really convenient way
of looking at things.
And I think this is what I'm trying to
get at with this whole series of
interviews and series of conversations
that I'm having with different hunters,
different vegans,
different,
there are different people that are
trying to ethically source their food.
I'm trying to get a sense of how the
hell this happened and how it's so
pervasive and how there's so much
resistance to understanding and
appreciating what the,
the,
the overall what the really big picture
of where our food comes from.
Uh,
what it actually is instead of this a
utopian view that I think like we were
talking about,
you had this idea before separating
yourself from this world of animals and
it's not just food obviously.
I mean every material that a city that
the city uses,
water,
huge issue here in California.
Huge issue in Atlanta,
Georgia.
Huge issue in many places.
That water's coming from somewhere else,
every material that,
that city uses.
Very little as being produced actually
the raw materials coming from that
location.
So we're constantly drawing on rural
areas,
you know,
far flung around the globe sometimes,
but certainly the immediate surroundings
and cities are utterly dependent on
that.
Yes.
And um,
plastic and then waste products.
And then,
you know,
I have a friend who's a surfer as a Yoga
teacher and he loves surfing and he's,
he's a real interesting cat,
kind of a free spirit.
Um,
but he told me,
uh,
he's lived all over the world and um,
it's kind of very bizarre accident cause
it's like a combination of like a bunch
of different places where you live for
10 years here in Argentina for 10 years
and he serves everywhere.
He went surfing in Los Angeles.
He went surfing in Malibu after the rain
and didn't know that you can't do that.
Like you can't because there's so much
waste that comes from our cities.
When it rains,
it pours into the ocean and it's like
you're bathing in a toxic soup.
So he was sick for days just from
surfing in the water right off our
shores.
Just from all these chemicals and paths
sloughing off,
landing all the oil,
all the,
the,
the residue brake dust residue that's on
the roads,
all of that.
When you have a pouring rain that comes
down that La River and it just goes
right into the ocean.
It was just,
they say for like five or six days,
you're supposed to stay out of the
ocean.
It takes a while to filter all that
stuff out and get it back to the where
the state that it normally is at.
But you know,
we live in this really dirty gross,
polluted city that's right next to this
beautiful ocean and there's
consequences.
Yeah.
When you took your first year,
was that,
what was that like as an experience?
Shocking.
Strange.
Um,
a definite tangible feeling of loss,
you know,
the loss of this life,
but also a,
an incredible feeling of exhilaration,
this weird primal connection when you're
actually eating the meat over a
campfire.
Cause we did it,
you know,
hardcore back country,
back country,
public land in Montana.
Off the Missouri River camping,
like the whole deal.
We did it the right way.
And uh,
you know,
you're around a campfire with a bunch of
people that you really care about and
you're all eating this meat from this
animal that you just killed isn't tense.
And it's,
it is the male bonding experience,
you know?
I mean,
this is like,
there's,
there's like football games.
Oh yes,
it's fun.
But hunting,
going out and hunting parties together.
I had a conversation with my friend
Duncan trussell yesterday about this,
that I think that there's some things
that we,
um,
don't know that we have a requirement
for in our minds or in our bodies or in
our,
and maybe perhaps in our DNA that our
bodies are set up with these certain
reward systems.
It's rewarding to gather up your own
food.
And Pete,
anyone who's ever grown a garden
completely outside of hunting gardening
is super satisfying.
It's amazing when you eat some food that
you've grown yourself.
When you're chopping up some Kale and
tomatoes and you're making a nice salad
and you made all this,
you grew all this yourself and you paid
attention to it,
you fertilized it and you added water.
There's this amazing feeling like the
exubera ration,
this like weird exhilaration feeling
when you're eating food that you grew
yourself.
And these things I think are these
reward systems that are in place because
it was always good to do that because it
ensured survival.
Just like helping other people.
That feeling of that good feeling,
you get.
Sure.
Helping others in your community.
Absolutely.
Helping us.
And also I'm hunting I think is in
there.
So it was,
but there's a bunch of weird things that
are in there too.
Um,
you know,
being uh,
sexually attractive is,
is in there too.
Having someone think you're attractive.
Like that's a normal primal reward
system that we all love.
And even people that are in committed
relationships,
like women in committed relationships
like to go out with their girlfriends
and dress up and look nice to get looked
at.
They do,
I mean,
they might not have any desire to find a
new man,
but they want to get looked at because
it fulfills these primal reward systems
that are in our,
in our bodies.
And I think archery is in there too.
I'm,
and I definitely think hunting and
eating your own meat from an animal or
from a fish or something that you've
gotten
and pulled from the wild.
One of the things about,
you know,
you say it's a male bonding experience.
One thing that's fascinating is that in
the,
so many of the old mythologies,
the deity of hunting is a goddess.
Well,
the earth itself,
right?
I mean Artemis and Diana,
you know that women,
and I know many,
many women who hunt and they,
you know,
have a,
just like men have a wide range of
experiences and views and values and
attitudes toward it.
Um,
but you know,
they of course also have this experience
of,
of giving life,
you know,
but they're actually mothers or not.
They have this potential.
Uh,
and,
and the combination of that,
um,
plays out differently for different
women.
But,
uh,
to both be a giver of life and a hunter
and a taker of life,
you know,
talk about being sort of spiritually
connected to the world and to life and
death.
Yeah.
The giver of life thing,
excuse me.
It's something that men will never
really,
truly understand.
There's no way.
I mean,
I have this whole bit I'm doing about it
in my act because we will never
understand what it's like to even have a
desire to have a baby in your body.
I mean,
that's so alien.
So alien to us.
And I think the earth itself,
the,
the thought that the earth and that
nature itself is a woman,
that nature itself is a mother,
a mother that provides mother,
that gives life and gives birth to life.
I mean,
it totally makes sense.
Women hunters.
It's a very interesting thing because
Steve Rinella wrote this really
interesting article about sexism in the
way we perceive hunters because a,
there was this cute girl who was going
on these,
uh,
African Safaris and taking photos with
these animals that she had shot.
And,
and,
uh,
all these people are so angry at her.
And this was pre cecil the lion.
And so,
um,
he had this take on it.
He was like trying to figure out like,
what is with all this hate,
like where's all this hate coming from?
And he believes that a certain
percentage of it is just sexism.
Is that someone looking at this girl,
like,
why is this girl going over there and
shooting a Kudu?
Like why does she do that?
Why does she even want to do that?
Then beautiful animal.
Why did she want to go over there and
shoot that?
And that if it was like some fat old,
ugly dude,
nobody would care.
But because it was this pretty,
I think her name was Kendall Jenner.
Joan's Kendall,
Kendall Jones,
Kendall Jenner's like one of the
Kardashians.
Right.
Probably.
So,
you know what I'm talking about it.
Yeah.
And she,
you know,
she had death threats and got hundreds
of thousands of facebook likes.
I think she's probably got more facebook
friends than I do.
Um,
and it was all really quick and really
fascinating.
How many pete,
but just turned out and uh,
and attacked her and you know,
the hunting community supported her and
a lot of ways,
but the,
the,
the hateful people,
the things that I would read about it,
a good portion of it was that she
doesn't have to do this.
If you want to eat meat,
you can go to a store.
I saw that stuff.
Sure.
The fly flyer and there's a,
there's a lot of really good arguments
for that.
First of all,
not,
not that you,
if you want to get meat,
you go to store.
But for real,
if you're going to fly all the way to
Africa to get meat,
that's,
there's no eco friendly in what you're
doing.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you're going to get a jet and you're
gonna fly 16 hours across the ocean to
go get meat,
let's be honest about what we're doing
here.
We're having fun.
Right.
Okay.
And I mean,
I think the,
you know,
like Steve or no,
I remember that article by Steve and I
think that there are a whole bunch of
different things going on in a situation
like that.
There's the
perception,
um,
of hunting,
particularly,
so called trophy hunting or so called
sport hunting.
And the language is really problematic,
right?
Um,
that it is about us,
you know,
and I say us,
the hunters who do that,
who I going to fly to Africa,
I don't,
I never done that and don't intend to,
but,
but a hundred and flies to Africa and is
whether they're hunting lions or kudu or
whatever they're hunting,
they're clearly not hunting that.
So they have food,
right?
Right.
So that ethic of respecting life and
therefore you take life for a serious
purpose,
including food.
That's an ethic that actually not just
in,
uh,
those who are criticizing trophy
hunting.
But in hunting traditions,
you know,
there are many wanton waste laws in many
states.
You cannot kill a deer and just leave it
there,
right?
Even if you have a hunting license,
it's illegal,
right?
That's understood as wrong.
Right?
And there are many traditional hunting
prayers from hunting cultures where
it's,
you know,
I took your life because I needed
the food,
the hide,
et Cetera,
you know?
Um,
so that basic respect for life and also
like in the Cecil case,
you know,
there was the fact that he was shot and
then 40 hours later killed the animals
suffered.
It was not a clean kill.
Right.
Uh,
and there was outrage over that,
that that ethic also is part of hunting
culture.
You don't do that well,
you also don't leave,
you know,
you don't take the head and leave behind
the rest of the body.
And it's one of the things that Rinella
said about line on thing.
He's like,
if I shot a lion,
I would eat that line.
And you can eat align I guess.
Right.
I guess,
you know,
they're edible,
but,
well he has this,
I'm sorry.
No,
I'm just saying that there are these
values about respect for life and about
animal welfare and suffering and so on
that are seen as being violated by
situation.
Likes the salt or by,
you know,
other hunters,
Kendall Jones or others who go over.
It's like you didn't need to do the,
why are you doing that?
You're not,
you just,
you're not using it yourself,
you know?
Well.
So does that,
to put it,
Africa is one of the problematic place,
but to,
um,
just to be,
in all fairness,
a lot of people go to New Zealand and
they hot over there and they
do bring back the meat is still
ecologically you're flying in a plane,
you know,
it's,
it's really kind of re,
but it is an ethical way to acquire
meeting.
In fact,
a lot of the lamb and most of the elk
that you buy commercially in America
comes from New Zealand.
So the import elk from there,
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
There's deer,
elk or red deer.
A lot of venison comes from New Zealand.
Lamb comes from a lot of lamb comes from
New Zealand.
They don't have any predators.
So if you ever been over there,
have you ever watched a video about it
last night?
I mean,
they have fucking enormous herds of
sheep.
I mean,
he'd never seen anything like,
it was insane and elk and uh,
uh,
well not elk,
stags,
red deer,
deer.
And they have so many of them and that
they,
it's really easy to go over there and
shoot them because they don't have any
predators.
There's no predators there.
And all the animals had been imported
there.
So,
you know,
New Zealand is a very strange place
cause it's almost like a paradise.
It's unbelievably large.
I've seen footage of it.
I haven't either,
man.
I've only seen footage.
Uh,
I want to go just,
I'm not even in hunting just as a
vacation.
I want to take my family over there and
just check it out.
Yeah,
it just looks so cool.
But I think in addition to the sort of
trophy in sports issues,
in terms of what is
objectionable to a lot of people about
certain kinds of hunting,
I think there also is in many cases,
not in the Cecil case,
obviously,
but in,
in the case of,
you know,
Kendall Jones and others,
there's also a gender issue.
There's also an issue about women as
killers.
Right.
You know,
and I think that is even more
disturbing.
I don't agree that that's the only
reason people jumped on it because
people jumped on the dentist too.
Uh,
but,
but I think it also,
it is troubling in a different way.
Dennis killed a lion that had a name and
that's where things got really weird.
Cause the anthropomorphization of these
animals that we've experienced in movies
and television shows and commercials and
what have you.
That's,
it gets real weird with people cause you
named something and all of a sudden they
think that that,
that thing is like someone's pad or
something.
Yeah.
I think the naming has a,
it certainly adds a dimension to it.
The fact that,
you know,
turned out to be,
a famous lion.
Um,
but you know,
there've been other cases,
um,
you know,
Donald Trump jr or you know,
one of the trump sons was right.
You know,
several years back.
Yeah.
It isn't all trump jr and it wasn't a
named animal.
No.
But still the,
yeah,
the whole trophy.
Right.
The image of trophies and you know,
you've got these,
you know,
these skulls of,
of deer and elk you've taken.
And I have some too
and there for me anyway,
it's not a trophy in the sense of,
Oh look,
here's what I did.
You know,
it's some,
you know,
some kind of macho proving,
that I'm a hang up in the living room
and show off.
It has some sort of totemic or a
symbolic power,
you know,
it reminds me of that hunt and it,
I don't want them not to just throw it
away.
It's something that I value and,
and,
and respect.
Well,
it's art.
It can be seen as art.
I think it's nature's art.
I mean,
that's why I don't have anything that's
been taken care of.
Like it's,
there's no stuffed things because
they're not real.
Like if you look at,
and I'm not knocking anybody that kills
an elk and wants to put,
it's a quarter on their wall or
whatever,
or put his head on their wall.
But the,
the bodies,
when you see those things,
it's a foam body and they tan the hide
and they stretched the hide over it and
it's,
it's so much,
it's fake.
These skulls are,
this is the actual skull of the animal.
And to me that is,
it's a beautiful piece of art.
It's a fascinating to me when I look at,
I mean that,
that's the mule deer,
the first animal I killed over to your
left right there.
I look at that thing every day and I
look at it and then every day I find
some new area on it.
The just the design of the deer skull is
fascinating.
And I mean,
I wouldn't ever shoot an animal just for
its skull or just for its antlers,
but I would never leave it behind
either.
You know,
I would want to keep that too.
Right.
And so,
you know,
the,
the idea of trophy and the language of
trophy and the symbols like cruelty is,
you know,
that's troubling for people.
Yes.
And I think it's important for hunters
to get better.
And,
and Steven Ellis spoken about this too,
to get better at
expressing what's meaningful about the
experience of hunting.
What's meaningful about the meat as
you've,
as you've spoken about a bit,
what's meaningful about a skull or
something,
you know,
what is it that is that is meaningful
and I,
I think people can actually understand
that if we can move past just black and
white hunting's good or bad,
trophy hunting is good or bad and that
kind of thing.
No,
I think they can too.
We're always going to have problems with
people that are really hardcore vegans
that have they've,
and it's really interesting,
I got in this conversation with someone
really recently about it where I found a
bacon lettuce tomato sandwich on their
instagram page if they were talking all
kinds of crazy shit about hunters.
And um,
she told me that she's only been a Vegan
for seven months.
She was like one of the most
outspoken,
angry,
forceful,
like every,
everything about it was like,
like it must be done.
You must stop.
This is a,
we're killing.
You have a blt on your fucking instagram
page.
Like,
what's happening here?
What is this?
The causes that well,
it's almost like when you get into
something for the first time,
you can't shut the fuck up about it.
And uh,
I've been guilty of that many times in
my life.
If I got into a race car driving or
something like that,
people in the podcast probably like,
will you shut the fuck up about race
car driving?
Right.
And it got to the point,
you know,
with hunting,
there's a lot of that like,
so to this day,
like I'll put this podcast hop and
people go,
oh great.
And other hunting podcast Zzz Zzz
I get it.
I don't care.
I'm going to talk about what's
interesting to me.
And also I think part of these podcasts
is these things will last for as long as
they get shared and spread around in the
digital form.
And I think these conversations are
important right now.
I think this conversation,
the conversation about where's your food
come from?
What made you make these choices?
I think these are important
conversations because I think the
disconnect and recognizing the
disconnect that we have between where
our food comes from and these attitudes
that we develop and have a that we
really don't,
don't have any problem with or we don't,
we don't think there's anything wrong
with the way we're alienating people or
pointing out the flaws over the people's
behaviors and we're not looking at
herself.
There's a blind spot there and then I
think this is,
is a very important conversation because
like I said,
I think we've created something really
weird with cities,
with cities and with with supermarkets.
We've created this really weird thing
where for our entire history,
the,
as long as people have been people we
knew where our food was kind of coming
from,
he knew you went to a butcher,
you got the food that butcher kill that
animal.
He knew you go to a farmer,
he grew the vegetables.
You knew that when they came ready to
yourself and those were that it was real
clear and now it's not anymore.
Now it's real weird,
right?
You go to a drive through and you give
them paper and within seconds you get a
ground to animal sandwich and you're
eating it,
the whole,
the whole process takes a minute and
you're eating something that's already
cooked right and you're drinking this
vat of sugary liquid with ice cubes in
it.
Like how the fuck the ice cubes,
it's 95 degrees outside.
Where'd you get the ice?
W W there's this weird sort of removal
from nature that we have and the natural
process of collecting and gathering and
then enjoying the food that you've
gathered.
Right,
right.
And for me,
the interest in reconnecting those
things and being aware of
where things come from and how they're,
how they're connected.
That is what led me to be a vegetarian,
but it's also 11 you'd be a hunter,
you know,
wanting to understand and recognize the
connection and not turn away,
you know,
and the turning away when people
willfully like,
I don't want to know that willful
ignorance.
Yeah.
That's the thing that bothers me.
I don't care if someone's vegetarian,
Vegan,
if they hunt or not.
That doesn't matter to me as long as
they're willing to at least look at what
and how things are connected and look at
what's going on.
One of the first reviews of,
of my book that was written was by a
vegetarian and she,
that
the book actually made her think about
going back to being vegan because she
was disturbed,
you know,
and she also said that she thought that
the author and she didn't know me,
um,
would consider it a compliment to know
that it led her in that direction.
And she was actually right because I
wasn't trying to convert her into being
an omnivore or being a hunter.
I was asking,
look at these issues,
think about these values,
think about animals,
think about nature,
think about our relationship with these
things and you decide what you're going
to do in your personal life.
You know,
and the fact that she could respect me
enough and anticipate that I would
respect her decision was great because
she wasn't doing that willful ignorance
thing.
You know,
I think we're lucky that there's so much
confusion.
I really do.
I think this is a fascinating time to be
alive.
And I think we're lucky that everything
is so bizarre because it makes these
conversations.
So the crackle because there's
something,
something so weird about it.
There's something so weird about,
uh,
civil as an animal,
a life form,
a species that has developed for
whatever hundreds of thousands of years
we've been people eating meat.
I mean,
that's essentially when you look at
scientists,
when they discover the,
the,
the difference in the size of the lower
hominids brains and humans' brains and
they're trying to figure out what the
fuck went wrong or right.
Rather where we developed this gigantic
brain or wrong or wrong.
Yeah.
I mean,
it could be wrong.
You know,
we got to get back to the garden,
right?
Um,
if it,
if it was what they think it is,
it's because we started eating meat.
We started hunting.
We had to develop ways to be more clever
and capture.
These animals were soft and spongy and
were very weak animals.
So we had to get smart.
And compared to the saber tooth,
tigers were really,
we're crunchy.
Yeah.
A ridiculous,
we cannot run anything.
I watched a video pull this video up
that I tweeted yesterday cause if any,
anybody wants to know how hard it is out
there,
there's a video of a Martin,
which is a,
uh,
an animal that a lot of people associate
with,
uh,
for trading.
And people go,
oh,
how could you kill a Martin Weasel
family big weasel and it's chasing a
rabbit.
And I don't know why.
I never thought of them as carnivores.
I probably should have thought of as
carnivores.
There's a fucking Martin chasing a
rabbit and it chases this thing for
hundreds of yards.
And this is a spread.
Look at this.
Look up at the screen.
I guess you do it right over here.
You look to your right.
You don't have to look behind you.
I think this thing,
so this Martin is chasing after this
rather unusual terrain.
Yeah,
well it's open road,
open road and ice and it's a dead heat
for awhile.
But the Martin is just slowly relentless
are closing in on this rabbit.
I don't know where these people are,
but they were speaking a different
language.
Um,
and the rabbits trying to zig and trying
to zag.
But the Martin is just one step after
one step,
just an inch closer,
a little closer,
a little closer and there fucking
hustling.
And this rabbit is like shit,
Bam.
And then he gets them.
But look,
look at this fucking evil little animal.
It is the size of the rabbit,
which is what's really crazy.
It might actually be smaller than the
round,
smaller,
probably lighter.
And he just,
we had jack that he had essentially the
same thing happened in front of our
front porch a year or two ago.
We were,
I think were on the porch or out in the
yard.
And suddenly we hear this squealing as
horrible Shriek and there's,
uh,
a young snowshoe hare,
you know,
little little rabbit and a tiny weasel,
like an urban,
I mean things like as big around as a
hot dog.
I mean,
it's tiny little thing.
Much small rabbit killed that rabbit.
They're intense.
They're amazing right there,
right.
That was,
I mean,
and I'm a hunter,
but it was host still horrifying to see.
And it's totally,
I mean,
it happens all the time.
Yeah.
Plants getting eaten,
animals,
eating animals,
insects,
birds.
I mean,
everything's eating everything all the
time.
Everything.
We don't see it most of the time.
Most of us,
unless we are out,
you know,
out in the outdoors a lot or paying
attention to the garden and you don't
see it happening all the time in Alaska.
And a brown bear killed a moose in his
driveway and they had to shoot the bear.
The people that,
you know,
whoever the wildlife management people
tried to shoot the bear because of
decided to bury this fucking moose in
his garage and he keep coming into his
driveway.
Yeah.
Or in his,
um,
his lawn,
like the,
like this is his territory now coming
back for that and there's a 600 pound
fucking bear who just killed a moose in
his driveway and that's not even a big
bear,
which is really terrifying.
They embarrassed for brown bears.
Yeah.
There's so big.
And to think that the,
and he loves it there and to think that
he's watching out his window like a
little piece of glass will thin piece of
glass,
the family's luck.
Oh my God,
look,
oh no.
There's a video of the same thing
happening of a,
of one habit.
There's a video of a bear killing a
moose in this family's driveway where
they're looking out the window.
It happens all the time because you know
these people that live in these parts of
the world,
especially Alaska,
it's so like you've got like anchorage
and then you've got wilderness.
You know when I was up in Anchorage,
we would just drive a little bit of,
Oh,
here's one right here.
Here's another one.
It's like fucking comment up there.
This is a bear that's dragging this
moose and this Mousse is,
I've seen this one.
This moose is dead,
right,
or is it still alive?
It looks dead.
This one's dead.
There's some where the,
there's another video.
We don't need to see.
A lot of these videos is enough,
but there's one where it's still alive
and it's killing it in,
in the driving things,
screaming and trying to get back up and
the bear drags it away and,
and alls it and yeah,
I mean it's,
it's tough for us,
you know,
as humans because we have this,
we have this moral conscience that
presumably the bear doesn't have right
about the suffering of another animal of
its prey.
You know,
and we do as hunters,
as farmers,
you know,
as,
as pet owners,
you know,
they have companion animals.
We have this moral compass of some kind.
What we're conscious entities are aware
of ourselves.
We have compassion and,
and a moral code built around these,
these sorts of impulses to protect
animals from suffering as anything.
And yet we see what happens in nature on
occasion.
At least we get to witness something
like that and we have to integrate,
you know,
what's real in nature,
the way animals do things.
You know,
our,
our moral frameworks aren't terribly
relevant in that world,
but we still evaluate them like say it's
evil in what I mean,
even if you don't literally mean the
Martins evil.
But we,
we have,
we think in those moral terms about
animals.
Yeah,
we do.
Well,
I think this is the real argument that
vegans have that we're trying to move
away from any suffering and this is what
they're trying to do by trying to take a
cruelty free path,
by trying,
trying to choose what they think is the
most ethical lifestyle.
What they're doing is they're sort of
answering this call of evolving this,
uh,
this call that they have of the evolving
species right away from away from
certain kinds of practices that we
historically who have abandoned,
you know,
not saying slavery has been banished
worldwide,
but we as a society said,
we're,
we can no longer do this.
And you have to evolve socially beyond
that.
And the argument which has,
you know,
some legitimacy to it in a sense is that
we have to evolve beyond eating meat and
so on.
Well,
that's why I think this conversation so
fascinating is because the,
the argument does have a little bit of
merit to it is not a black and white
issue and neither is what you would call
quote unquote trophy hunting.
That's not a black and white issue
either because Zimbabwe just announced
they're going to call 200 lions because
they've outlawed lion hunting.
So now they have a surplus of lions.
Have a problem with the Angela to
getting decimated.
So like,
all right,
we've got to fucking kill some lions.
And each one of those 200 lines that
they're going to call would have brought
them $50,000 of revenue towards
conservation that would stop poaching,
that would,
uh,
keep wildlife habitat.
There.
It's,
it's a really complicated,
and the people that are on the outside
conveniently ignorant to all these facts
that are incredibly complex.
Um,
they,
they're not,
they're not aware of this big picture.
Like,
I'm not saying you should go to Lyon to
Africa and go hunt lines.
I don't want to do it.
I'm not going to do it.
I don't have any desire to kill anything
like a lion,
but to that part of the world that
brought in a considerable amount of
revenue and there's a balance that they
attempting to
achieve with the predators and with the
prey.
And that balance is kind of screwed up
now that they've taken out hunting of
lions,
which is hard for people to imagine,
you know,
cause you'll read about Africa that some
areas the lines are threatened.
You know,
there's this really interesting pace
that I follow on instagram called save
the lion.
They have all these really cool photos
and lions and I think lines are amazing.
I'm glad they're around.
I,
I like looking at videos of them.
I would love to see them in real life
other than a zoo,
you know,
but you get too many of them.
You've got a real problem.
And the only animal that can figure that
out as us,
it's it,
there's,
you know,
the goats aren't going to get together
and go,
hey man,
we've got to fucking do something about
this mountain lion population.
We're just,
there's no more goats.
We've gotta,
we've gotta we've gotta help you.
No,
no,
it's,
it's only people that can count the
number of wildlife biologists that can
figure out what's the right amount and
people that can study the results of
having a disproportionate population of
predators and realize that we've got to
do something about that.
Yeah.
I mean,
the Predator Predator predators are
really complicated all over the world.
I mean,
here they're complicated in Africa,
the complicated in many parts of the
world,
um,
ecologically in relationship to pray.
You know,
if,
if we had a very large area and we just
weren't part of the picture,
it's not as though predators would just
completely wipe out the prey.
They will run out of food as prey gets
harder to catch.
Prase not going to disappear entirely
just because of a lion,
you know,
group of lions or,
or wolves a or any other kind of
predator.
They will ebb and flow.
They have different sort of states of
equilibrium,
high density of both low density of both
changes and those sorts of things happen
in relationship to us and our different
interests,
agriculture,
livestock,
you know ungulates that the local human
population values.
Then it gets really complicated.
And you know,
the issue you're bringing up about,
well they're calling lions and it could
have brought in so many tens of
thousands of dollars from hunters and
I've just been working on this essay
about these sorts of issues.
There's all these practical issues about
money conservation and those sorts of
things that are happening in Zimbabwe
for example,
or other countries or here.
And then there's the,
the moral and ethical issues around
animal welfare.
And is it respectful of life to kill an
animal just for the head or do you have
to eat it?
And so there's,
there's a language of practicality.
What does the Zimbabwe need to fund
given programs,
how do you fund that?
And then there's the whole discussion in
language of,
of the morals and ethics of it,
which is,
you know,
those are active discussions among
hunters too.
Yeah,
they really are.
And the end they should,
because again,
this is not a black and white issue.
It's very complicated.
You're talking about a country like
Zimbabwe,
which is incredibly poor,
which could have benefited from $1
million in money that would aid
conservation if they allowed these hunts
to continue.
So each one of these 200 lions that were
killed would be worth $50,000.
Know that's a,
that's fascinating cause it is.
It is.
Cause it's not,
it's not really that simple.
And also Africa's enormous and this is
something that a lot of people don't
consider either.
When you think of Africa,
you hear,
well lions are in danger while they're
in danger in some spots.
But you know that's like saying,
I looked out my yard today,
there's no deer.
Okay well go to upstate New York.
There's a shitload of them.
They're everywhere to the point where
they're,
they have to hire assassins essentially
to go in and call the deer because
they've got so many of them.
They've got to go in and shoot them.
I mean this is,
this is a big problem in a lot of places
on the east coast.
There's areas in Pennsylvania that don't
have a hunting season for deer and in
people's neighborhoods.
You could just shoot them all the time.
They want,
they bring an archer's.
There's this television show,
there's archery bowhunting show where it
was in the middle of the spring and uh,
they,
they brought in these archers to set up
tree stands in these like residential
neighborhoods.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
The rebound in white tails and you know,
in the country as a whole,
but particularly,
you know,
along the eastern seaboard has created
some bizarre,
bizarre situations,
particularly in suburbs.
The animals that used to be symbols of
the wild and still are from any of us
are hanging out in people's lawns.
Not only that,
that giving people lyme disease,
that's a big concern about that.
That's a big concern.
Ticks that carry lyme disease.
They say something like 60% of the ticks
in New York state have lyme disease,
some insane number like that.
I just made that up.
Check,
check,
check.
But it's some really bizarre Lee high
number of ticks in certain areas of
upstate New York where there's a giant,
a prevalence of deep bolt dear and um,
and lyme disease that they have a huge
issue and they really don't know how to
stop it.
Cause lyme disease is devastating if you
get it.
It's horrible on your immune system.
It's rough.
Yeah.
I can get into nervous system,
do all sorts of things.
Do you?
Yeah.
And that's also a problem that happens
when you have overpopulation of deer.
There's all chronic wasting disease,
a bunch of different diseases that come
through overpopulation and you know,
and it's uh,
on the chronic wasting disease of
course,
that,
you know,
the risks associated with that brings up
the whole sort of captive deer hunting
industry and issues when that they start
moving animals around,
then maybe carry cwd or other diseases
and then they have contact with wild
populations
and while they're doing these,
this is part of the whole trophy hunting
thing that's so bizarre.
They're doing these fenced in
establishments where you go and hunt and
you're hunting these animals that have
been grown just for their enormous
antlers.
We covered it a couple of days ago with
my friend Doug Durham and uh,
we showed some photos that animals that
don't look like deer,
they're bizarre.
Yeah.
They have like these weird sculptures on
their heads like bushes,
right?
Like a Bush growing out of their head.
Like,
yeah.
It's just so much,
so much antler material.
It just doesn't make any sense.
Yeah.
It's a huge industry.
The Indianapolis Star,
I think a few years ago did a really
good long form expo's a on,
on that whole industry.
And it is bizarre.
Isn't that just how it's always going to
be though?
I mean,
if you have any sort of a,
a discipline and he sort of a pursuit,
you're going to have people that are
unethical.
You're going to have people that are,
uh,
you know,
race car drivers that are using just
stronger engines and they're supposed to
use or cheating somehow or another on
this or on that.
Or it's just,
it's how it is all across the board in
life.
Sure.
And that people who want to do that,
whether it's legal or not,
and how much industry is allowed to be
built up around it.
Right.
So you have like the hunting industry or
the hunting community,
the hunting world,
you're going to have people like
yourself that are doing it to provide
their family with sustainable meat.
And then you're going to have a guy who
wants a collection of different animals
from all of the world's stuffed in his
room so he could show everybody,
you know,
like,
this is my zebra room.
You know,
like you ever seen those fucking guys.
It's,
it's terrains,
man.
I was watching the television show once
and this guy brought these people into
this room that looked like a high school
auditorium and he was just like the
super wealthy guy who hunts all over the
world.
That's all he does.
And it was just like a stuffed zoo.
It was the strangest thing.
Birds and fucking baboons and all these
stuff things.
I'm like,
this is the weirdest guy.
This guy's like a serial killer of
animals,
like some weird thing that he's attached
himself to.
Yeah.
One of the things that's tricky is
because
such a relatively small percentage of
the population here in the states hunts,
you know,
it's,
how small is it?
You know,
it,
it varies depending on how it's millions
of people,
millions of people.
It is.
Um,
but you know,
it's on the order of 10% will ever take
what percentage of Vegan fewer than
that.
But again,
it's a small number,
right?
In La,
I bet it's higher vegans to hunters.
I bet the hunters are way out numbered
and this fucking Koofie city.
It could be,
I would imagine.
Uh,
but because,
because it's this true for Vegetarians
and vegans too,
because we're a minority population,
it's really easy for
most people to have sort of a stereotype
view and to lump them all together.
You know,
and the analogy I sometimes draw is,
you know,
because such a huge percentage of the
population drives cars,
we can distinguish between good drivers
and bad drivers.
People who get into road rage and people
who were polite.
We can distinguish these things and we
have understandings of it because we
experience it and we see it and we don't
judge people for being drivers or lump
them all together.
Right.
You know,
but any minority community runs the
risk.
This is true for Vegetarians to,
for hunters.
True for any minority community.
We run the risk of being identified as a
sort of a monolithic singular group.
So you get,
you know,
a hunter who portrays a certain image of
hunting and if fact,
oh,
that's what hunting is.
Boom.
Yeah.
You know,
this,
this identity gets attached to all
hunters.
And not,
I'm not saying it always happens,
but there's a risk of that.
Um,
and I think the part of the gift of this
time,
particularly in relation to the food
movement,
you know,
Michael Pollan's work and is that people
are asking questions,
people are thinking about agriculture
fuel,
thinking about wild foods.
People are thinking about their
relationships ecologically and ethically
with what they eat.
Yeah.
And I think that's great.
I think,
uh,
I think it's a good thing.
I think these weird sort of,
um,
stereotypes that we have about,
about hunters,
they're really easy to do in this day
and age.
It's really,
it's,
they're attractive.
You know,
from the time Bambi was released,
it's attractive to lump hunters into
this evil.
Like if you see hunters in a movie,
they're almost always these cruel
assholes.
Like,
did you ever see the movie wolverine?
No.
Rain got mad because there was a bunch
of hunters and they poisoned a bear and
he beats him up at a bar.
They're all mean people like that
anymore.
A wolverine.
What do you eat?
And Dude,
look at the size of you.
Fuck,
you know,
what do you eat?
And Hugh Jackman and ain't lentils.
You know,
you're eating a lot of meat.
I bet it's,
it's a strange,
you know,
it's this strange thing that we have
decided because we're conveniently
removed from the process of killing the
animal,
seeing the animal alive,
see,
killing it,
butchering it,
chopping it up,
and then cooking it.
We just get to the gimme a piece or even
more disconnected.
We'd go to a restaurant,
so disconnected.
It's like we're 18 steps removed.
Sure.
It's,
it's real convenient to look at hunters
like some horrible evil thing.
You know,
like I said,
one of the,
my favorite is the people that eat meat
and say,
you don't have to do that because you
can just go to the supermarket.
Why would you want to do it?
You only do it because you're cruel,
but they can't imagine that you would do
it because you want to kind of
understand what are the consequences of
what you're doing.
Is this what you want to do?
You know?
I mean,
I think
you're right about the,
the movies,
excuse me.
Um,
from Bambi having that kind of,
um,
cultural impact and portrayal of hunters
as,
you know,
a force of evil and being sort of anti
nature,
right.
You know,
the,
the sort of disruptors of,
of this
eden like natural world.
Um,
and
I think that a lot of times hunting
industry and hunters today and the media
around hunting,
forget how the rest of the world
perceives like the,
the trophy photo.
Even if it's an animal you're going to
eat,
you're smiling with the picture.
Oh,
you know,
as like what is seen in that from
someone who's not experienced that and
doesn't know.
Is that a image of respect for the
animal?
What is the,
if,
if a hunter is expressing joy in that
picture,
is it joy?
Is that joy at the death?
Well,
what's going on?
You know,
and those sorts of images in,
you know,
tv shows and just photos posted online.
I think it's hard for,
and,
and it's almost even hard for me,
you know,
but I think it's hard for a lot of 900.
It's like,
what?
What does that mean?
It's a,
it's kind of disturbing.
Well,
yeah.
Is it that you're happy that you
accomplished this very difficult thing
or is it that you're proud of yourself,
that you're a killer,
right.
Or you know,
are you a,
are you posing with this thing because
it's your trophy and you win,
you know,
are you cruel?
Are you happy because you're happy,
you're smiling because that's what you
do for cameras,
you know?
And I've never been terribly comfort.
I've taken photos like when I've hunted
and succeeded in and the first time I
did it I,
you know,
took a photo of,
cause I want it to be able to send it to
my uncle.
Right.
But I wasn't smiling.
I just,
for me it was like I had to have to
force a smile.
I'm actually not,
I don't experience the same sort of rush
that some people do in it.
Um,
I find hunting meaningful and I find
that moment incredibly powerful.
Um,
but it's never been only until just this
past fall I finally took a photo that I
actually felt
I read that I really felt good about,
you know,
and I would,
what were you doing the photo?
It's actually on my facebook page.
I think my books facebook page,
it's,
the deer was down and I was just
kneeling there and have my hands on the
deer and I was just,
you know,
just being in that moment with that
animal,
it wasn't about,
you know,
the camera,
it wasn't about smiling,
it wasn't about this is what I
accomplished.
It was just,
this is an important,
there it is right there.
Yeah,
that's,
that's like the first time I've taken a
photo after a hunt that really felt good
to
me.
You know,
that's a great picture.
that's a great picture because boy that
is the wild.
I mean,
you are in the woods and that's less
than a half a mile from home.
That's awesome.
Great Place.
And you're there with a really wild
deer,
a nice big mature whitetail that was
probably at the end of his voyage and
took them out.
Um,
I've posed with pictures of animals that
I shot and I've done it smiling because
I'm happy because it's difficult to do.
It doesn't take away from the reverence
that I have for the animal,
you know?
Uh,
especially elk.
Elk are,
in my opinion,
they're like almost like a mythical
creature.
I'm very,
very happy when I,
when I've killed an elk,
especially the one that I killed with a
bow because it's so hard to do.
It's insanely difficult.
There's the same amount of pressure and
when it's over,
when you've accomplished it.
Like if I,
if I get ready for a rifle hunt,
I cite my rifle in,
um,
I go to the range,
I squeeze off a few rounds,
I make sure my form is good,
I make sure my trigger discipline is
good and I'm ready to rock.
I'm good to go.
If I am thinking about hunting in
September,
I will start preparing in October for
the following September.
I'm not bull around.
Yeah.
Cause once I started hunting with a bow,
I realized like this is insanely
difficult.
This is not something you can kind of
dabble in.
And I know some people do and I don't
know how the hell they do it.
Um,
maybe they just don't,
maybe they're not,
they're not worried about the
consequences as much as I am.
Or maybe maybe,
I dunno.
Maybe they're just better at it than me.
I don't think so though.
I just think,
I think archery is something that you
have to do all the time.
I don't think you could take 10 months
off of archery practice for a couple
weeks and be as proficient as if you
were practicing those entire 10 months.
Most of the people that I know,
there's meet with,
uh,
an elk that I shot.
I'm happy right there.
People got mad at me for that picture.
But it's,
it's hard I think for people who,
you know,
you've experienced that you were there,
you know what you felt,
you know what your reverence was for
that animal.
You know what you were happy about you,
you know,
I'm happy it died quick to write you.
You know what all the things that went
on there.
Yes.
As a snapshot to someone who's never
experienced anything like that,
it doesn't,
they don't know any that you look like a
a mean person who's happy that you've
just killed.
Exactly.
That's,
yeah,
exactly.
There's so much going on when it,
when it comes to a photo with that
animal,
because it's not just about,
look,
if I took that photo just for me,
that's perfect.
If that's just my photo and I keep it on
my phone and I,
and I go,
I want to look at it every now and then.
This is the moment where I shot that elk
and I was really happy that I was able
to make a clean shot.
The animal died in seconds.
Everything went great.
All my training paid off,
all the hard work,
all the thinking,
all the preparation,
all the paid off.
But that's not just for me,
that's for everybody else too.
Right.
But that's also why it has a really long
paragraph attached to it where I went
into,
usually there's not that context.
Yeah.
Well for me,
I think it's very important.
It's a,
it was very important.
It was important to thank my friend
Cameron hanes because without his help
and without his teaching,
me,
I,
it would have taken a lot longer to
learn how to get good with a bow and to
understand,
uh,
how did,
what a difficult pursuit it is.
And just to keep your nerves together.
When this thousand pound tree full
forest horse is coming up the hill
screaming at you and you have to shoot
that thing with a bow and Arrow,
you know,
there's a lot going on there man.
And there's consequences is,
I think,
decides to kick your ass.
There's not a whole lot you could do,
you know,
that's know.
Have you ever hunted elk?
Whenever I was,
I was out in New Mexico this fall for,
I had a writing residency down there for
a month and I had a,
a mule deer tag for a few days at the
end of that,
um,
I did not end up shooting,
uh,
didn't shoot it all when I was down
there at an animal.
Um,
saw a few deer,
um,
and,
but saw a few elk close.
I wasn't hunting them,
but they came through.
We,
we heard him comment links like,
wow,
that's almost like a moose up where I
am.
That's a big animal.
They're pretty close,
pretty close to the size of a moose
there.
Awesome man.
They're amazing.
They're so cool.
There's
her and I heard at least one beautiful,
which was wild.
I'd never heard it might hurt,
you know,
I heard a tape of it,
but I never actually heard one view.
What,
what time of the year was it when you
were there?
I was there in October
when I go.
Um,
I'm going to go hunting again in
September and I'm going to bring my kids
and on one day,
um,
I'm hoping that I could be successful
and have a day just to take them out and
bugle for them and just make some cow
calls.
Just they can hear the screams.
Cause it is amazing,
man.
I eat for someone who's never been like
in a canyon while they're all around you
screaming as the morning light is
coming,
coming up.
It's,
it's one of the weirdest things and all
of nature and the fact that this is
going on in the American wilderness and
the vast majority of people that live in
this country will never experienced that
outside of hunting.
Just take the hunting out of it and
just,
just be there.
And here
it's this huge barrel chested thousand
pound animal screaming at the top of his
lungs.
There's really nothing like them.
Yeah.
And you know,
the fact that we have these populations
of these animals,
these amazing,
amazing animals and the,
and the places,
you know,
it's a big debate that I know Steve and
Mel has been involved in the politics of
public lands.
You know,
there are a lot of people who want to
turn,
you know,
federal lands over to the state and
privatized
a lot of that.
So a lot of that off.
And that's a big issue with a lot of
Republican politicians.
It's one of the reasons why Rinella
considers himself a political unit.
He's like,
the Democrats wanted to take your guns
away and the Republicans want to take
your land.
And it's a,
it's real interesting.
This land that we have in this country
was established,
this,
these wild lands.
He's public lands by Theodore Roosevelt.
And he established it because he was a
hunter and a conservationist and he
realized like,
you've got to lock this stuff down.
So I need,
you know,
John,
we are founding a Sierra club who yes,
who had a lot in common with Roosevelt,
disagree to them about hunting.
But equally important,
you know,
equally committed to preserve,
you have Samedi preserve these places.
We need,
you know,
not everything has to be helped like,
but we need public land and even
Yosemite's an issue,
man,
they're,
they're calling buffalo now.
They're,
they're shooting bison,
Yosemite or yellowstone.
Yellowstone.
Sorry.
I always fuck those two of those wise,
you know,
it's just a yet at y I guess.
Um,
but uh,
yellowstone with the bisons they're
having a real issue.
You know,
they have to,
they have to call them now and people
that are,
that want to be able to hunt yellowstone
or kind of angry about the whole thing,
they're eventually going to have to
call.
Some of the grizzlies are saying,
cause the grizzlies are getting too
crazy and they're getting too
comfortable with people you have,
they have real issues even in Yosemite I
think with bears not,
you know,
getting in people's cars and yeah,
we'll put you open your car.
Like,
I can't open a ticket a apart.
Yeah,
I smell food.
You're good night.
I know.
Even a smaller blackberry,
he just can't believe how strong those
things are.
Amazing.
We,
because we live in the woods,
I mean,
we have them come investigate our house.
Sometimes you'll see the prints or I've
seen him on the back porch,
you know,
through the screen.
Right.
It's like,
hi.
I mean,
and they're pretty skittish.
like,
we are there,
you know,
they do not hang around people.
Um,
and so I have to do is make noise and
they take off.
They're not really dangerous to people
at all,
but it's pretty neat to be that close to
them.
And you see even a small one,
you're like,
oh,
that's a pretty good sized,
powerful Animal Rinella.
His friend,
um,
took this young guy,
uh,
like,
I dunno if it's one of his relatives or
whatever.
Took him on a black bear hunt a while
they're sleeping.
It took them on some kind of haunts.
I don't even know if it was a black bear
hunt,
but while they were sleeping was
attacked by 500 pound black bear in his
tent.
Um,
big melee and sue's,
everybody's screaming.
One of his friends shoots the bear and
hits this kid.
Then his first hunt ever in the elbow
shatters his elbow with the gun.
Yeah.
The,
the whole thing is chaos.
They wind up killing the bear.
Seven foot tall,
500 pound black bear that had come to
kill this kid.
Malden cut them up pretty bad.
But yeah,
bears are,
there are crazy
thing that if they weren't real,
I mean if a grizzly bear wasn't a real
creature and you saw it in a movie and
be like,
what?
Like it's a star wars it animal and a
lot of ways very powerful.
Yeah.
And you know,
it's amazing to think about,
you know,
traditional subsistence hunting cultures
that hunted bears of that scale went
into their den sometimes that's pretty
hard core.
Oh,
it's so crazy.
You know,
you have to do what you have to do to
stay alive.
And that's what again,
we can't appreciate that.
Yeah,
we are in some strange state now.
We're our meat.
We associate meet with a thin plastic
wrap over a styrofoam tray.
Right,
right.
That's me.
You know,
going back to the idea of,
you know,
animal people and spirituality,
I'm thinking about these sort of
traditional hunting cultures too.
There's this great film documentary
called Diet of souls that was done by
this guy,
uh,
up in the north up in like Alaska.
And one of the basic questions in the
film is how can an animal be your
spiritual equal,
which is how it's thought of in many
traditional,
you know,
hunting cultures there you're equals,
they aren't just animals.
You,
they're powerful.
And,
and yet they're also your daily bread
there also what you eat every day and
how does that get integrated in these
traditions?
And it's,
it's,
it's pretty fascinating cause we don't
think,
you know,
as a sort of Western civilization,
we've developed these [inaudible],
the lower animals and the higher
primates,
as you know.
Yeah,
right.
We have these,
this sort of hierarchy and we'll eat the
lower ones or the ugly ones we talked
about,
but the ones that are equal to us or
higher or better,
or maybe there's nothing higher,
better than us in Western civilization
and I in our imagination Unicorns,
right?
Unicorn,
Rainbow Unicorn.
Um,
so we've had this convenient way of,
of creating this hierarchy and,
and,
and thinking of ourselves sort of being
at the top of this pyramid in some way.
Um,
but in cultures that see themselves
still is very much part of a more of a
circle of peers,
you know,
in the community and yet also are eating
these animal people all the time is a
different world view.
Well,
vegans will say,
well,
why don't you start eating people then
if you want to be all spiritually
connected to your food.
Right?
How about hey friends,
I respect you.
I'm an eater now you're going to feed my
whole neighborhood,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
there's,
there's something that we appreciate
about these native American cultures
that had a deep reverence for the
animals that they change and European
cultures for that matter.
Know what ancient European,
well,
I mean pre,
you know,
before agriculture,
before um,
Christianity,
you know,
we have traditions and all of us,
they go back,
you know,
arguably all of us back to Africa or all
parts of the world where,
you know,
we had,
the,
the caves of Lascaux in France,
you know,
were painted by ancient European people
who had probably a somewhat similar,
um,
shamanistic spiritual and hunting
relationship with these other animal
people.
You know,
well,
the first time I went deer hunting,
I really do believe that like locking
eyes on that deer and about being about
to shoot it,
I feel,
I felt like it was some weird
psychedelic experience in some sort of a
strange way.
It almost felt like I had taken a drug
because I felt like there was some
strange connection or some strange
frequency that I had tuned into that
never been a part of before.
I'd never experienced that before.
Now I could,
you know,
I had a protein bar in my pocket.
I can go back to camp.
We had a cooler full of food.
I was still pretty detached even while
being interconnected.
But those people that painted those
paintings on the walls in the caves in
France,
they were desperately connected,
intensely connected and they were
without the burden of our are are these
sort of strange moral ideas we have
about what's okay to eat and what's not
okay to eat and what's ethical and
what's not ethical.
They were free from those burdens.
And yet in,
in hunting cultures for thousands of
years,
honey has been surrounded by ceremony,
right and ritual and you know,
been very much part of the religion
celebration.
But also,
um,
you know,
ceremonies for,
for sending the hunters out and
ceremonies for welcoming them back in
because you are out there doing violence
to another large mammal and those
ceremonies and those sort of a religious
or spiritual practices are different
from but also kind of similar to how
we've dealt again in,
in big time history,
uh,
in the large scale,
how we've dealt with warfare.
You know,
how you send a warrior out and then
welcome on warrior back into the
community after he's gone out and done
violence to other human,
to other humans.
And that case is different.
And yet they're also,
you know,
if you're doing two other animal people,
so you know,
the buffalo people,
the dear people,
um,
there is still a similar,
you know,
moral ambiguity about this,
it's,
they were free in a sense from some of
the baggage we carry now.
Sure,
I think you're right.
But was there still moral ambiguity
about taking life and needing to respect
that animal by using it fully?
And I think so.
There was ambiguity,
but there was certainly probably a
deeper reverence,
um,
and an understanding of the,
these were inevitable decisions that
people had a Mac,
whether it's to defend your life against
other humans that want to take your life
and can take their life instead,
or whether it was to eat an animal that
you hunted.
There were,
there were sort of unavoidable.
I think so.
Um,
I mean,
what year do you think it was for?
The first Vegan was invented,
it was it the eighties.
I'll probably tell you earlier than
that.
Sixties could be,
I have no idea.
But it had to be within a hundred years.
Right.
I mean vegetarianism,
it's been around for a long time.
It's been around for a long time.
Even here,
I mean since the 18 hundreds came over
as part of this Christian group from,
from England,
um,
and has been around in other parts of
the world for much longer,
you know,
in India and other parts of the world.
Um,
veganism is I think a relatively new
invention.
Tammy's got to answer the Vegan society.
1944.
Okay.
A couple of decades off the first modern
day vegans,
in November of 1944,
Donald Watson called a meeting with five
other nondairy vegetarians including
Elise Shrigley to discuss nondairy
vegetarian diets and lifestyles.
All right.
Forward.
And he died of a common cold a week
later.
So that's what he was a non dairy eating
vegetarian in 1944 that was back before
they really totally understood how to
get your vitamins and what the amino
acid profiles of vegetables were too.
So taking somewhere chances back then.
Yeah,
no,
I probably had very little little idea
what they were doing nutritionally and
well that's the weird thing too,
when people like the show a picture of a
gorilla and show the gorilla only eats
vegetables,
you can do it too.
Um,
or you know,
we're not gross.
Try feeding the cat on the vegetables.
They go blind.
Yeah,
they did not.
They did not do do well and then people
still do it.
I know,
I heard you were talking about that on
one of your shows reading about it
today.
I was reading another article about it
today,
this morning about Vegan cat owners.
Yeah.
It's tricky.
Go Blind.
Yeah,
it's not,
they're obligate carnivores.
They must eat well.
So much so that they actually have to
add taurine to cat food because a lot of
cat food just in the process of loses
that loses taurine like they're brutal.
They are the fucking cleanup crew of
nature.
The cats and anything with a limp gets
taken out.
You know,
and I have these two cute fluffy ragdoll
cats.
They're the sweetest cats in the world,
but they're fucking vicious man.
They're vicious to each other.
They definitely a vicious,
the catch something outside.
I had kept,
my cat was 18 years old and she killed a
bird in the courtyard.
Fucking,
yeah.
Teen.
The estimates on the number of wild
birds,
you know,
songbirds that are killed by cats,
both,
both domestic and feral in the states is
it's like a billion a year.
I'm not kidding you.
It,
they think it's the,
the biggest threat,
I believe it's estimated to be the
biggest threat to a wild songbirds in
North America because cas,
they are hunters.
They are hardcore and there's way too
many of them.
There's so many of them.
And you know,
people love them as pets.
Yeah.
Here it goes.
Three point billion,
7 billion birds annually.
All my God.
Cats that live in the wild or indoor
pets allowed to roam outdoors,
kill from 1.4 billion to as many as 3.7
billion birds in the continental u s
each year,
3.7 billion birds in the continental
United States.
So your kitty cat and that bird feeder
bad.
Oh my God.
That is amazing.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
What a crazy animal a cat is.
They're just these little killers that
allow us to take care of them and they
pick them up and they per,
because they just can't eat you.
You're just too big.
That's really the relationship.
It's my friend is a cop much better than
saber tooth tigers.
Yeah.
My friend's a cop and he said one of the
craziest things was where they would
find people that had died in their house
and they have gats like conscious,
go right for your face,
eat your face off.
So they'd find this person who had died,
you know,
we could go and they just ran out of cat
food.
The cat just eats your face.
What is this domestic oh six point
9000000020.7 billion mammals.
Mostly mice.
Shrews,
rabbits,
squirrels.
And I don't know what a volt aa is.
Vol.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like a mouse a little bit each year
according to a study published last year
in nature communications that you saying
between 1.4 and 3.7 billion birds and
6.9 and 20.7 billion mammals.
While I'm not a big fan of mice,
so fuck 'em I like cats.
Not,
not big into mice.
I pick sides.
We all pick.
So we did.
We do.
You know,
and that's,
you know,
when we have a cat that's part of our
family or a dog as part of our family,
and obviously they're,
they're very different species,
but they become family,
you know?
And that's another vegetarian argument
that has a real logic to it and has an
ethic to it of well,
you wouldn't eat your dog.
Why would you eat a deer or a cow?
Right.
And yet
we as,
as a species,
you know,
we're very tribal.
We identify with a group,
whether that's all humans or whether we
have,
you know,
will that become dogs,
you know?
Yeah.
And Hunt with us or,
or cats that we,
that we adopt for various reasons and
that,
you know,
that group becomes,
family.
You don't have your family.
No.
Well,
if you ever watched that,
um,
Penn and teller show,
ah,
bullshit,
they had an episode on animal activists
and the people for the ethical treatment
of animals,
like,
like what the roots of their argument
and their ideas are,
they don't want pets.
They don't think we should have any
captive animals.
No pets,
no pet dogs,
no pet cats.
Everything's free to roam and do as it
will.
Um,
and no eating any animals,
which is like,
oh,
what kind of,
where are we going to live in then?
Well,
there was a,
there's a fascinating,
I think it was a Cleveland Amery who,
one of the founders of the fund for
animals.
I believe I have this right.
Um,
had a vision,
you know,
of,
the future world and it was separate
predators and prey separate them.
Like in the,
in the wild,
like,
so how do the predators eat magic magic
unicorns?
I mean,
yeah,
that's hilarious.
So he wanted to stop any sort of cruelty
even in nature,
right?
Right.
Well then you're gonna get cannibalism
done.
I mean,
there's already a huge problem with
cannibalism and the bear community like
bears,
when male bears come out of dens,
they actively search for cubs.
They want to eat cubs.
It's one of the first things they do.
They do it to try to bring the female to
estrus.
And they also do it because they're
hungry and they,
they're cannibals.
When I was,
um,
in Alberta,
some friends of mine run a hunting camp
up there and they saw a male bear kill a
female bear's cub.
And um,
the female chased the mail off the
carcass and then the female finished it
off her own baby.
She's eight at once it was dead.
She started eating it and they were
like,
whoa.
And they said they had been around.
I mean,
these people,
they live in northern Alberta.
Okay.
They've been around some animals and
wildlife their whole life.
And they were like,
eat free.
Even for us,
that was like,
whoa.
Yeah.
Because there's really good
documentation and research also,
you know,
that animals and not just,
Orkos there's some dolphin,
something that we assume is or bill or
have good evidence that they're at a
really intelligent,
um,
that they have a wide emotional range,
you know,
and including grief,
including mourning for the death of
family members,
including their,
you know,
the calf.
You know.
Um,
so there's,
it's,
and I think this is one of the
unfortunate things that happens is that
when we get into these black and white
struggles,
you know,
hunters versus animal rights activists
or anything like that and he's similar
kind of black and white,
is that
each side has its argument and each site
doesn't really want to acknowledge too
much that there might be some validity
to either the argument on the other side
or just to the reality of the world.
Like animals have feelings,
not just they can physically suffer,
but they have emotional,
you know,
they have emotions.
You can see it in your dog.
You can see it in wild animals.
Sometimes they have emotions and that's
tough.
And often on the hunting side it'd be,
oh,
that's just so-called anthropomorphism.
We're,
we're,
you're just projecting human.
While there's pretty good research on a
wide range of species that they have
emotions as well as the ability to
physically feel pain and suffer.
Uh,
and
I think it's really helpful when we get
into these kinds of conversations across
those lines to be able to at least
acknowledge,
you know,
yeah.
Or acknowledge where,
you know,
Peta,
or other animal rights groups at least
not acknowledge where they're coming
from.
You might not agree with the arguments
that are conclusions,
you know,
same as,
some people might not agree with you
hunting,
you know,
but at least acknowledge there's a,
for you hunting,
there's a,
a valuable experience and an ethical
impulse to,
you know,
confront what it means to eat meat,
for example,
for Vegetarians and,
and animal rights activists of various
kinds.
There's an impulse to prevent suffering
and respect life.
You know,
they're honorable and understandable
impulses on both sides.
Even if we don't agree with you know,
what all the kids,
yeah,
I think,
and I think it speaks to what we were
talking about earlier about reward
systems that are in place to ensure
survival and ensure certain types of
behavior and activities.
I mean it only makes sense that an
animal would feel remorse if it's child
got killed.
That's why you take care of it and
protect it.
I mean if you've ever seen a mother cow
around it's calves,
if you go near those calves,
mother will go crazy and it's,
there's built in systems that are
established to make sure that these
animals continue to procreate and
continue to stay alive and make sure
they have healthy populations.
It's just the same reason why our
emotions are in place.
I mean it's all really kind of a grand
scheme to ensure breeding and ensure
community and ensure all these that mean
we will call it emotions,
we'll call it civilization,
we'll call it communication between
sentient beings.
But really it's what it is,
is all these different systems that are
established to make sure that we stay
together,
we keep together,
we breed,
we ensure that we stay alive and
continue to have food and make sure we
make more people.
And I mean it's,
I don't want to break it down it's crew
and say like,
you know,
all,
all romance songs and every,
every book on,
on companionship is bullshit.
Every movie that shows an awesome
relationship is just a ridiculous
biological trick that's established to
make sure that you continue to stay
alive long enough to make more people.
But really that's kind of what it is,
you know?
I mean,
I don't,
I don't want to break it down so much to
that because I think there's beauty in
all of it.
You know,
there's beauty and love and oh look,
there's,
in a strange way there's beauty and
watching that grizzly bear mall,
that Moose in the middle of the
driveway,
this beauty and watching that Martin
chase down that rabbit.
I wouldn't want to be the rabbit,
but I'm not really sure I want to be the
martin either.
You know,
I mean,
I don't,
I don't think I have to identify with it
to appreciate the spectacle,
the amazing spectacle that nature is
providing.
And you know,
the,
we,
we throw the word awesome around a lot
now,
you know,
the last 10,
20 years.
But the old word,
awe know the power of that.
And there's beauty,
but there's also sometimes borderline
horror fear.
But,
but nature is awesome in that life and
death and our own lives and deaths,
you know,
the creation of life,
the taking of life,
watching it happen around us doing it,
it's theirs off.
And there's beauty.
There is undeniable,
undeniable,
ah,
you know,
I watched this documentary on Komodo
dragons and they're intense.
Oh my God,
there's so gross.
But they're so awesome and they're
gross.
Snus and one of the things about it was
how they will bite like a water buffalo
on the leg and their mouth is so toxic,
really toxic,
so toxic with bacteria in their saliva,
sub funky,
that just one bite and that thing's
dead.
So they just follow it,
wait around,
and they wait around a couple of days.
And slowly but surely all the toxic shit
from their mouth.
Like,
Oh yeah,
no,
thank you.
Yeah,
that's not even,
you don't even see their teeth.
And that one,
like look at the one above it where you
see their teeth.
Oh God.
I mean,
what a crazy animal.
And that's another thing that I think is
amazing and beautiful is just the
biodiversity of the world that these,
and I think,
again,
I hate to keep bringing up the same
theme,
but I think we've done ourselves a
disservice by creating these cities.
We've done ourselves an amazing service
in that.
Look at that.
All the Fox,
which ruled off of his face.
What a fucking,
I was like drastic park or something.
He'd be the monster.
Komodo dragons are funky slide coming
out of his mouth.
But we've done ourselves.
I mean,
we've made an incredible thing,
you know,
it's incredible that we,
we don't have to go out and hunt our
food.
So because of that we could develop by
phones.
We could figure out how to make four g
lte and better laptops and cars that
drive themselves and all this cool shit
that we have.
It's amazing.
It's great because without,
without our easy access to food,
none,
no one would have the free time to
develop all this stuff.
So I think it's imperative that we do
have cities imperative that we do have
an easy supply of food because
you're not gonna get all this electronic
equipment and all this stuff that we
have.
We're just not going to get it if
everybody has to forage.
So we've,
we've enriched our lives in this way,
but in doing so,
we've somehow,
or another forgotten that there were a
part of this wild world.
We're part of wildlife,
we are wildlife.
We're just not wild anymore.
We're wa or if we are wild,
we're not wild in the sense that the way
we look at the rest of the wild world,
but,
right.
But we are,
sure,
and I mean there's,
there's arguments in anthropology that
actually,
there were lots of societies that had a
lot more leisure time than we do.
You know,
hunting,
gathering societies.
It's been,
you know,
four to five hours a day,
quote unquote working hunting and
gathering and had lots of time for,
you know,
ceremonies and all kinds of other
things.
It depends on where you are in the world
and how harsh the conditions were,
but,
but the,
you know,
sort of the original leisure society
May,
it may have predated.
He did agriculture,
certainly they had no i-phones and
maybe,
maybe that was a blessing,
who knows.
But four or five hours of hunting and
gathering is exhausting,
you know,
and you really don't have enough time to
develop a car.
No,
no cars.
Yeah.
After you've figured that out,
after you've done your hunting and
gathering,
then it's about cooking and,
but also there's no days off because you
don't have any refrigeration.
Right.
Depending on,
you know,
depending on your climate.
I mean,
they could,
they could try things and do certain
things,
but clearly,
clearly not the,
not a frigidaire around the corner,
but you know what you're talking about,
about whether it's cities or just modern
society,
that
high tech,
high speed world that most of us live
in,
where many of us don't feel like we have
much free time and we're running around
and doing all these things in cities.
Usually.
Um,
when I talk to people who become hunters
as adults,
by and large,
that's part of why they did it.
They want it to reconnect.
Yeah.
You know,
it's part of why they garden.
It's part of why they raised chickens.
It's part of why they do all sorts of
other things that you understand and
value to.
They want to get back in touch with
those.
Not only the hands on skills,
but just the world they inhabit.
You know,
beyond the domesticated concretized city
concretize,
you know,
you know that word,
you know the pavement,
you know,
beyond the payment into nature and
whether it's a little garden patch in
your backyard or hunting around the
Missouri breaks,
you know,
there's a sense of wanting to reconnect
so that all of these practices,
hunting,
gardening,
raising chickens in part are like an
antidote
to modern life.
You know,
people want to reconnect to some of that
or is it,
or are we clinging to the past and
trying to ward
off the inevitable?
Right.
Are we trying to ward it off this
inevitable symbiotic relationship we're
going to have to,
computers are going to be a planet or
hoard.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
have you read Richard Lubes work at all?
No.
He um,
he was a journalist,
I believe for many years.
His first really famous book was called
last child in the woods.
And then his followup book was called
the nature principle.
And how long ago?
This is kind of,
um,
let's see.
Last child in the woods came out,
what,
2006.
I could be wrong about that date.
We'll,
we'll know in a moment,
I think.
Um,
but you know,
his argument is in part,
how do you spell the last name?
L.
O.
U.
V right there.
I'm sure this,
it looks very serious.
Look at him.
He's a,
he's a neat guy.
Um,
and his argument is that we all need
nature for our mental,
physical,
emotional,
spiritual health.
First he focused on kids and then he
moved it to focusing on 2005,
I guess it was the first book.
Um,
and he says that actually the more high
tech we get,
the more we need these sorts of
experiences.
And he,
he's,
he's not a hunter,
but he does fish and he spends a lot of
time outdoors and that we need that
neurologically mean,
not just,
um,
in some romantic sort of throwback
fantasy.
But we deeply need it because we are
wild.
And what does he use to establish that
argument that we need it?
I mean,
he's got all kinds of,
you know,
research and you know,
umpteen citations of,
of different sorts of,
of studies and cultures and different
things that happen to kids at first.
And his first book and then,
and then two adults,
if we're deprived of that,
if we're always in front of a screen,
for example,
if we're just never out in the dirt,
you know,
never out in the woods.
Um,
we certainly evolved in the real world
in nature,
not in cities.
Right.
Um,
and our,
you know,
we're hardwired for that three
dimensional textured,
um,
I mean,
I guess there's textures in the city
too,
but,
but that kind of natural surrounding,
I'm in whatever climate,
that's what really nourishes us,
not just physically in terms of food,
but keeps us sort of sane at some level
as a degree.
We're still saying,
yeah,
that's the argument.
Are we saying and is saying even a re a
rational request or,
uh,
just,
hope is it,
is it,
what is saying?
What is sanity and our sanity?
What's health in comparison to the
Saturday of someone who lives in a
tribal environment in the Amazon?
I mean,
they
would look at us and laugh and go,
yeah,
you're not saying you people are fucking
crazy.
He went crazy for 2000 years.
Yet.
What are you doing?
You know,
like,
I don't know who's right because I don't
want to live in the jungle.
Right.
You know?
I mean,
I think they're crazy.
Like you don't even have tvs and it's
easy to,
it's easy to have that either or like
now in the city,
you know,
or where in the Amazonian jungle.
Yeah,
no,
this is not some kind of romantic
throwback.
Oh,
we should go back to the garden.
You know,
it's not that.
But that these experiences that you
know,
the experiences that you have gardening
with the experiences you have hunting
are deeply human,
valuable experiences for us.
And to not have them have a culture and
they have an individual life or a whole
society that has no connection.
It's all supermarket.
It's all drive thru,
but big MACs,
you know,
during the time that we're not hunting
and we're not gathering and we're not
farming.
There's time for philosophical pursuits,
creation of literature,
all sorts of writing and different
communication and wonderful
conversations over meals.
You had no part in creating and the
building of community and the bonding of
friendships in the evolving of ideas
that a lot of these things can be
thought of by some people as being more
valuable than the collection of food.
Sure,
absolutely.
Uh,
they could be,
and I think that the,
the risk is in having it be like,
oh,
we have to go back to the woods and live
in the woods to be real humans.
No,
no,
no.
That's not,
or say that's just ancient history.
Give it up.
Stop having these fantasies about the
past.
Just live in our cyborg future,
right.
To be healthy human beings.
Whether it's uh,
you know,
just to walk in a park or being part of
a community garden in a city,
you don't have to leave the city.
You can have some experiences of
connection with the,
you know,
the earth,
right.
In La,
you know,
you can have some,
some,
well,
I always wonder,
and this is like a reoccurring theme
with me,
like what are we,
what are,
what are we doing as a race,
as a species?
Like if you could step outside of
ourselves,
if you could hover a mile above earth
and your objective free from any
influence of our culture,
you are some calculating being that sort
of as gathering up all the data and
information and all the behavior
patterns that you're seeing exhibited by
this bizarre species.
What is this thing doing?
Well,
this thing is creating technology.
That's what it's doing.
It's,
it's,
it's involved in some sort of uh,
ever accelerating path of innovation
ever accelerating path of creating new
and better technology,
new and better devices,
new and better things,
and it works all day in order to obtain
the latest and greatest of these things.
And that therefore fueling
the creation of these things while
longing for the past while longing for
some little house in the prairie type
fucking situation where,
you know,
everybody died of polio and those
terrible time to be alive,
but you look at it on tv and you're
like,
oh,
it was awesome back then.
My grandpa.
Yeah,
we,
we long towards the simple past we
longed towards,
you know,
people that would hold hands in front of
the dinner table.
And say our prayers and,
and everybody was a good person except
for the few bad people wore black hats.
You could spot him a mile away.
You know,
I think in this ever more and more
complex life.
We,
we long towards this time where things
were simple and it's one of the things
that I believe is very appealing about
the idea of hunting and gathering your
own meat.
And it's very primally enriching because
we do,
we do reward our,
our system.
We,
we give ourselves the opportunity to
participate in those reward systems that
are set up and they've been established
for thousands and thousands of
generations.
Yeah.
I mean it's one of the only ways.
Yes.
Do so and that,
you know,
that experience that you talked about
like locking eyes with that deer and,
and having that intense experience,
uh,
have seen at your live the intense
experience of taking a life
and how,
my sense as you were describing it is
that the,
the prime wellness of that in part is a
sense that this is really familiar.
Yes.
This is really old.
You know,
like a cellular level memory.
This is old,
old stuff.
And you know,
for me,
when I,
when I took my first year,
it was so shocking emotionally.
Um,
I'm a shocking,
I finally succeeded.
I was surprised of the usage you try
for.
Um,
I did not succeed the first three years.
how many days were you going out?
It's a,
it's on the main season we have in
Vermont as a two week rifle season and I
wasn't able to hunt the full two weeks.
Um,
usually it was,
you know,
less than half of that time probably,
um,
a little bit in other seasons,
but mainly it was in the rifle season,
so it wasn't really years of hunting.
That was weeks of awning stretched out
over years.
But the deeper shock was,
you know,
as you say it sort of that sense of loss
of life,
you know,
that for me it was a sense of grief that
this beautiful animals dead.
Right.
And do I ever want to do that again?
I really wasn't sure at first.
And you were by yourself this entire
time?
When I took the deer.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I was by myself.
Um,
and
it was the process over the next few
days of,
of butchering that dear,
that
felt really familiar.
You know,
it was almost like a ceremony.
I'll,
you know,
I was doing this,
the knife and the,
you know,
skinning and then in the kitchen with a
leg on and taking apart this amazing
animal,
all these layers of muscle and bone.
And that is what gave me the sense of
this is really old and familiar and I'll
probably do this again,
you know,
in another year,
maybe not next week,
but next time deer season rolls around,
I'll probably hunt again.
Um,
and that sense of deep sort of primal
familiarity,
um,
is common.
I mean,
I've heard,
I've read accounts of this people who
are not hunters,
but who have had a sort of hunting like
experience,
um,
uh,
George Monbiot or Mamby,
I'm not sure how you say it.
Um,
he's from the UK and has advocated for
veganism and against beginnings at
various times and,
uh,
or conflicted gun.
Yeah.
Uh,
but,
uh,
very much in ecology,
environmental advocate,
he has this passage that he wrote about
having this experience of,
I think it was being with a like a spear
going after fish,
like flounder in shallow water and his
ex,
his account of it is very much,
this felt like it was thousands of years
old.
Like this primal connection with ancient
human existence.
And I think it's valuable for people,
even if we live in a high tech world,
to have some connection to that.
Well,
I think these are genetic imprints.
These are,
these are things that are written into
our code that it was really important
that you kill an animal in order to
survive x amount of thousands of years
ago.
Those people that did that and bread,
I believe they gave that genetic
information to their offspring and they
carried on,
on and on and on.
And then when you tap into it,
it lights up.
Like when I locked eyes,
that deer and the deer was bouncing
around on the side of this hill and it
saw me and I saw it and I locked eyes
with it.
And then I'm looking at it through the
rifle scope.
There was like this light bulb that went
off in this area of my mind that was
illuminated for the first time.
It was like,
check out this part,
like you don't even get in here without
doing this.
And it was like,
oh,
this is what the hunting thing is.
I get illuminates this ancient genetic
variable,
this ancient genetic pathway and it felt
psychedelic.
It felt like I was on a drug and I'm not
like not like a lustful,
I must kill and we know it was like this
weird sort of,
it's an altered state.
Yes.
Animals,
spiritual connections.
Very strange.
Strange experience,
which I was shocked.
I was shocked.
I expected the sense of loss.
I expected the,
the sorrow.
I expected all these different,
the sorrow never really came.
There was a sense of loss,
but there wasn't a sense did something
wrong.
There wasn't a sense like I shouldn't
have done it and part of it was also
because I was seeing bones everywhere
and mountain lions shit.
I'm like,
this is the Goddamn war zone I'm in.
You know,
when you're in the breaks,
you,
you find these ropes of shit.
And I say ropes because shit that was
filled with hair because these animals
were just jacking deer and whatever the
hell else they got ahold of.
Well,
you know,
we're in a war zone.
It was a nature war zone.
So I didn't,
I didn't for a bunch of reasons.
And also because I knew it was gonna eat
it.
I didn't feel bad about it,
but I did feel like,
wow,
this is intense.
This is intense.
But the surprising part was the altered
state.
And I feel that still,
I mean,
it's changed over the years.
I've been hunting for the dozen years or
so now,
and it has,
my experience has changed.
It's,
no,
it wasn't,
it's not a shocking and quite as intense
as it was the first time,
but it still remains powerful.
And I'm still in an altered state for
like hours or days afterward and a state
of thankfulness too,
which is also like there's a warm
happiness to it,
uh,
thankfulness that you are successful and
now you have this meat and you're going
to provide this mean to your family.
You know,
like my friend Duncan sent me a photo of
some um,
elk meat balls that his girlfriend had
cooked for them and their friend from an
elk that I,
some elk that I gave him.
And it made me feel so good that my
friend was eating some meat that I had
given him from an animal that I had
killed.
I mean,
great.
You're grateful to the animal,
to the lands and then grateful to be
able to provide,
I mean,
I'm grateful that you,
you,
you have this established community
feeling bond feeling with your friend
who you give them meat and cooking this
meat and he takes a photo of it and,
but it's all bizarre,
you know,
like this digital representation of this
thing and it's sent to you through the
air and smell it and arise on your
phone.
You know,
like,
hey man,
we're in the woods,
Bros.
This is nature.
It's kind of sort of weird,
you know?
Yeah,
it is.
It's all,
it's all very odd.
It's all very odd.
And I,
I do wonder if what I'm doing by getting
into hunting and is just clean til the
last remaining gasps of a dying world.
It's possible.
Yeah.
But I sure hope it's not really dying.
Do you do much hunting outside of your
home state of Vermont or is that mostly
what you do?
That's mostly what I do.
I mean,
I've hunted a little bit Danna
Massachusetts where I have a friend and
my uncle,
um,
I've got it out of state a little bit.
Do you go on trips?
He said,
I've never got on a moose trip or I
haven't,
I mean,
Moose technically do get hundred of
Vermont and small numbers.
Um,
is it hard to get a tag?
It is,
yeah,
because it's such small numbers.
Um,
but I haven't really,
except for when I was in New Mexico,
but was in New Mexico already
for something else.
Right.
And I've never really gone on,
uh,
a hunting trip somewhere far away.
And I dunno,
I might some point,
I have a friend who's been trying to get
me out to Colorado and I have,
I have a friend who lives in Colorado as
well for deer elk either either.
Um,
and,
and I love,
you know,
this particular friend in Colorado I'm
thinking of,
I'd love to hunt with him.
You know,
he's a guy I'd love to hunt with,
really enjoy his company.
Um,
but it,
I don't have like these fantasies of
big,
you know,
big western or Alaskan hunts or
whatever.
And so you're hunting is almost like,
um,
you're doing it almost entirely for
food,
you know?
Yes.
But if I just wanted food,
there are much more efficient ways to
produce that.
I could raise chickens,
right?
Sure.
It's a guaranteed thing.
You,
unless the,
they get taken out by predators or
disease or something.
You,
you raised these chickens and then you
have meat or you raise chickens and have
eggs or so on.
Um,
so the prime motive for me to hunt as
the prime motive for humans to hunt when
it started,
you know,
way back is food.
And that's essentially why I hunt.
But there's often been this split that's
been drawn between this distinction
drawn between hunting for utility,
utilitarian food and hunting because you
enjoyed a hoe,
you enjoy hunting,
you know,
what do you call that?
Sport hunting or recreational hunting or
whatever you call it.
And
the problem with that is that one,
for most of us,
they're not separate.
I mean,
you hunt because you enjoy something
about hunting and it's meaningful to you
and the food is meaningful and you get
food from it.
That's why I hunt both of those reasons.
Traditional subsistence hunting
cultures,
those people love to hunt.
Yeah.
They also totally depend on the food.
So both,
it's both,
you know,
it's not really a separate thing.
I don't think it probably really ever
has been for any hunting culture.
Um,
so more fishing or fishing.
Exactly.
Right.
So it's for both.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's enjoyable.
And there,
you know,
if it wasn't enjoyable,
we'd probably find other ways to,
we wouldn't do it.
And that's probably why it's enjoyable
because it provides food.
I mean it stimulates these areas that
we're talking about,
these primal need areas,
right?
So yes,
food is my primary sort of motive in
terms of a,
a product materially,
materially food is my motive.
It's not to have a big of antlers on the
wall.
If I end up with a big set of antlers,
I'll probably keep that skull and
antlers like you do.
But it's not the point,
right?
But it's the experience of it.
And as I got into it more,
as I started to have more relationships
with other people that I really
respected and who also hunted,
then it's also part of that if I'm
hunting with someone,
you know that I really enjoy their
company.
So there's social and you know,
natural experience motives that are very
much just about the process and the
experience.
And then there's the food,
but they're all,
they're all interwoven.
Yeah.
I think there's some people that want
you to feel bad about it.
So they don't want,
they don't want you to be enjoying it.
Sure.
And if it was,
I sadistically enjoyed killing.
Right.
I would find that disturbing.
Yes.
And I do find that disturbing when I see
people talking about or acting about
hunting or anything else.
That way I don't care whether it's a cat
or a dog or a wild deer or to
sadistically enjoy
causing pain and,
or taking life that's,
that's problematic.
Which is one of the reasons why,
that's the number one accusation that
anti hunters will label on hunters.
It's,
you're a sadistic person you enjoy
doing.
This is the only reason why he possibly
do this
and when.
But when you say you enjoy hunting,
if the understanding is what you enjoy
is simply that moment of taking life,
there's nothing else about it that you
enjoy and what the way you enjoy that
moment is sadistic.
Right.
Not the kind of light bulb goes off in
some part of this ancient,
you know,
human mind that
that's a different kind of in this
altered state.
Some people might describe that as
exciting or pleasurable,
I guess.
It's not like a,
as you said,
it's not for you a lust to kill.
No,
it's not that.
But there's something that is magnetic
and powerful about it.
Yeah,
there's something insanely primal about
it,
but one of the weirder things that
people lobby at you,
um,
that the people,
the insults that they send your way.
One of the big ones is you can't get an
erection,
so you go kill animals or you have a
little penis,
so you kill animals like it,
it gets brought to this weird sexual
lust thing.
That's I,
I'm really confused about.
I always get confused.
Like what is the root of that?
Because so many people go to that one,
like they go to that one.
When I,
whenever I watched even no matter who
the hunter is that people are attacking,
like whether it was the Walter,
the the dentist guy who killed Cecil or
whatever.
It's so many of them go to that,
that it's,
this person is sexually inadequate so
they're going out and killing animals.
There's this bizarre connection.
I don't understand that one.
And now maybe we should just blame Freud
for,
I don't know.
I mean maybe,
right.
I mean,
part of it is we have a tendency to,
to in our society and culture maybe
since Freud to,
to link any kind of like aberrant
behavior or,
or motive or desire with sex.
Yeah.
Which is crazy.
Um,
but there's also been a longstanding
story that's been told,
uh,
by critics of,
of hunting,
um,
that,
you know,
violence toward animals through hunting
is the same as sort of sexual violence
toward women.
And that women like mother Earth did
associates between women in Earth and
nature and men are these dominating,
domineering Thailand,
macho,
evil,
right.
And,
and there's a,
you can sort of see the logic and the
sort of cultural roots of all of that.
Um,
part of the problem.
And then Mary Mary Stage wrote this
fascinating book called woman the
Hunter,
um,
back 25 years ago.
Uh,
and part of her argument,
she's very much a feminist,
you know,
and,
and a hunter.
Uh,
and part of her rebuttal to that
parallel around sexuality is that
the same story is told both by the sort
of mainstream culture that portrays men
as domineering and women as nurturing.
And you know,
men is as violators and women as
victims,
you know,
which has happened certainly
historically that relationship exists,
right?
Right.
But the parallel to to nature,
um,
as ma'am the hunter as a cultural myth
myth,
which is very strong in,
in our culture that the critics I sort
of ecological feminists and so on,
the critics of that are retelling the
same story.
It's men play this role and women are
inherently nurturing,
inherently
not the sort of sexual violent,
you know,
lust driven,
sort of male.
Uh,
and her argument is,
let's break this down.
Let's also have women as hunters being
honored and respected and accept that
strong women and hunting
okay
can be compatible.
And women are not inherently
nurturing,
always.
They can be life takers,
they can be hunters,
you know,
they can provide for their family
through,
through taking life.
And hunting does not have to be
motivated and isn't motivated for most
hunters.
By some bizarre,
twisted sexual thing.
Yeah.
You know,
whether it's women or men,
that's not what the real experience for
me really.
Meaning I think there's just,
it's just a simple,
goto criticism.
They like to latch onto it.
I don't think if you,
if you gave them,
uh,
a quiet room and said,
okay,
why do you think people hunt if you,
if you wanted to,
if you're correct,
you're gonna win $1 million.
So I want you to really do your best to
try to calculate and formulate their,
the actual process that's going on in a
person's brain when they're hunting an
animal.
[inaudible] either guarantee you they're
not going to go with,
get it up there.
Not because then they want to get that
million bucks.
They would,
they would try to figure it out and they
would try to be objective about it.
It's a,
it's,
it's a cheap go to insult.
You know,
I think,
I think it is,
and I think that when it's something
that's when people here
a hunter talk about the experience of
hunting,
the way you're talking about it and what
that food means and what that moment is
like when they hear that,
they respect that in general,
you know?
Right.
Most non hunters who do,
I have no experience as long as they
meet.
Most likely though,
even even some vegetarians,
I mean,
right.
And some of the attorneys,
we'll make exceptions for meat that's
been hunted.
Right?
I mean,
they can really respect that in general.
It's when there's no experience of
someone speaking about it that way.
And it's just some picture of some guy
with some zebra or,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's so in comprehensible.
It's so removed and then there's
no,
there's no story that can be understood.
Right.
So it's kind of,
I get having been a Vegan and having had
a pretty dim view of hunting myself for
a long time,
um,
and having,
having had very strong feelings and
still having very strong feelings about,
about animals.
I get where that hostility and outrage
comes from.
You know?
Right.
And I can understand why someone would
even come up with that sort of bizarre
theory.
Yeah,
I can as well a lot of ways.
Um,
w w w without again,
like if I wanted to win $1 million,
they left me alone in a room and I'd
never had it before.
And if I wanted to come up with a mode
of that wouldn't be on the list,
right.
Because I don't really believe it.
I don't think anybody else does either.
But before I first haunted,
I was thinking to myself,
I'm going to either going to become a
Vegan or I'm going to become a hunter.
That was what this,
when I first went hunting,
I was saying,
well,
one of the things can happen either when
to shoot this animal.
I'm going to be horrified with myself.
I'm going to be like,
I'm going to eat this animal and then
I'm done or I'm going to become a
hunter.
Um,
I just,
I feel like this is one of those things
that will not be solved.
This is one of those things that the,
the debate will continue to rage on.
And I see both sides.
I,
I absolutely see and admire the motive
that the ethical vegans want or are
attempting to pursue.
Um,
I also see the intense hypocrisy when I
find out they have cats.
You know,
I mean it's,
it's super common,
you know,
and amongst my friends,
I have a good French wages to the comedy
store.
She's got a bunch of fucking cats and
she's a Vegan.
She gives people a hard time about meat,
like pitch,
you're feeding your monsters and
vampires.
You live with you bringing them home
dead things and they're probably
bringing her home dead things to figure
it out probably if they get out.
Yeah.
Um,
I just think that the,
this is,
uh,
this is sort of a stage,
um,
that human civilization is going
through,
that's going to take a few hundred years
and in that few hundred years or so,
we're going to evolve to be something
that's almost unrecognizable to,
in comparison to what we are now and
that we're going through this process
and in this process where longing or
longing towards the idea of wearing a
flannel shirt and going into the woods
with a bow and Arrow,
you know,
like that's what grandpa did know.
GRANDPA seemed happy all the time.
Oh,
grandpa didn't even have an email,
you know,
and he was happier for it.
He might've been,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't,
you know,
is,
is there anything that's been surprising
about this process and,
and creating this book and all this
stuff,
you know,
it goes back in a way where this
conversation started because you asked,
you know,
how much grief did you get?
How much flack did you take?
And what's been most surprising in a way
and,
and most rewarding,
uh,
is,
hmm.
That I've had opportunities to talk with
such a wide range of people and I've
done
seminars for a hunter education
instructors and I've talked to you know,
rooms full of non hunters,
including some vegetarians.
And the conversations have been
remarkably
respectful and civil across those
different and signs in the same room
size is a mix of those people in the
same room.
Um,
I went,
um,
very similar to this sort of experience
you're talking about with what it felt
like to hunt and,
and actually take an animal.
I went out to Colorado,
um,
two,
three years ago and did some seminars
for hundreds Keisha instructors and I
was a little uncomfortable because of
the topics they
asked me to speak on was,
uh,
ethics.
And I thought,
I'm a new hunter.
I mean,
I just started a few years ago and
here's all these lifelong hunter is
pretty much in this room.
75 guys,
mostly guys.
And I'm going to tell them about hunting
ethics.
Like,
oh my God,
how am I going to preach to them?
Right?
Uh,
but it went well.
And as soon as I opened it up for q and
a and we got into discussion,
these guys are talking really deeply
about the experience of taking life and
the sort of emotional dimensions of that
and they're talking to each other and
challenging each other to bring that
into the classroom with their students.
I was like,
wow.
Two days later I was just outside
boulder and I'm sure you know boulder
boulder's the button of every joke in
Colorado and vice versa,
you know soapies exactly.
You know,
so they say,
you know,
all the,
the,
all these hundred education instructors
were actually joking about boulder.
We were,
we were up in the mountains at this
place,
but they were joking about boulder and
they said,
you know,
how do you get to boulder?
Well,
you go to the edge of reality and you
turn left
and it's always laugh.
The joke is always,
of course,
yeah.
I'm probably one of the most liberal
places on earth.
Right?
Yeah.
And of course boulder,
that stereotype of boulder is telling
the same jokes are different jokes,
but jokes in return about evergreen.
Well,
yeah.
no,
I mean about the rednecks.
Yes.
And the hunters.
Yeah.
And you know these,
you know all these hunting jokes and
redneck jokes.
I was in boulder because I was being
interviewed by this x vegetarian who ran
this a show for Gaiam TV,
this online TV station.
It's all eastern spirituality and you
know,
all that kind of thing.
Okay.
Exactly.
The people who would make fun of each
other.
Right.
A hundred education instructors and guy
MTV.
As soon as we got into the conversation.
Yeah.
We're talking about the emotional and
ethical dimensions of taking life.
She's an ex vegetarian.
She's now eating meat,
but she's not a hunter or she's thinking
about these issues about confronting
life and death,
and when I got done the trip,
I looked back,
I was like,
wow.
Okay.
Those two conversations were really
similar,
complete different communities who
normally would think they had nothing in
common,
especially around hunting and yet the
very basic human questions,
the basic moral,
ethical,
emotional issues around taking another
creature's life,
especially a big,
big mammal.
It was a similar conversation and so
that's been,
I guess in a way,
one of the most rewarding and surprising
things about about the whole process and
the and the journey since is that you
get to see and talk with people in these
places where you know there's common
ground.
Yeah.
In different cultures,
you know,
radically different communities demar
there most certainly is.
And one of the things that I'm hoping is
going to common ground
or bring some common ground or at least
bring an understanding is the emerging
science behind understanding the
intelligence of plants and that plants
are in fact a life form that we take for
granted because they're not in motion
because they're stationary w and they
slowly grow and we were,
we don't really,
you know,
we don't really associate them with
being a life form,
but they are a life form and they're
strange life form that has some form of
communication.
Some of them can make calculations,
some of them in fact rare,
but they exist.
They're carnivorous there.
It's a strange type of life.
And as we grow to understand that life
deeper and deeper and have more respect
for it and really understand what it,
what exactly they're doing when they're
making calculations,
what exactly they're doing.
The communicating with each other,
how this network of,
uh,
intertwined lifeforms,
similar plant life forms that exists in
this topsoil,
which is also some sort of a very
bizarre ecosystem of life that these
electrical impulses that they're sharing
with each other or some sort of form of
communication and,
and Miss Holst traditions.
Yeah.
The spiritual dimension is not going to
be animals,
but plants do.
Yes.
And that this is the,
this is an unshakable,
undeniable truth that life eats life.
And we are,
and we,
and every animal on the planet is
utterly dependent on plants.
Yes.
Yeah.
All of them.
None of us are none of us that are
photosynthesizing.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't know if there's any way ever to
get away from what we've established in
this country with a giant numbers of
human beings and these population
centers and the factory farms.
It's support these population centers.
I don't know what the way of getting
around that is,
but I do think that people like yourself
and uh,
other people that are proponents of
least removing your own existence from
it in as clear a way as possible by
doing some growing and gardening by
doing some hunting,
by experiencing the wild of this world
and going out there and getting into it
and understanding of this is this is,
this is a real environment that coexists
with the city during the same timeframe
on earth and you,
we all,
I think,
I don't think as a person that looks at
those factory farm videos and goes,
oh yeah,
awesome.
Fuck those calves.
Yeah,
I'm glad those chickens get stuff to
those boxes,
I don't think is a single person that
does that.
And I think that's also why those ag gag
laws are in effect to protect those
businesses.
Because if that stuff gets out,
people get horrified and then they vote
with their dollar and they,
they make choices that reflect the
horror that they experience when they're
watching those videos.
Sure.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know if we can all collectively
as a group get out of this,
but I think as individuals we can start
moving away from it.
You know,
I think what you're doing when you were
or what your friends are doing when
you're talking about these people that
used to be vegetarians and now they're
the grid,
their on chickens now they provide food
to these other people.
Like that's ideal.
You know,
finding the people that are involved in,
in growing and butchering this meat and
getting it from them.
Like it's a cleaner,
easier way of,
of existing [inaudible] I don't,
um,
I don't,
I don't know if we're ever though with
the,
the amount of people that we have
stuffed in the cities.
How else,
Eh,
my people,
we have stuff on the globe.
Yeah.
That's insane.
How else are we going to get them fed?
We fucked up.
Yeah.
If you were to that objective being
hovered bugs they,
wow.
What a mess.
Yeah.
It's almost like,
um,
uh,
an insurmountable student debt.
Like what did you,
you're not going to pay this off.
How are you going to pay this?
What did you do?
You can't feed all those people the real
way,
you know,
Oh,
you've got to keep stuffing chickens
into factories and then you've got to
keep stuffing these pigs into warehouses
and then,
or,
or something.
I don't know what that something is.
You know,
I don't know what the other alternative
is,
you know,
I dunno.
Um,
anything else before we wrap this sucker
up and how it's been great fun.
Thanks for doing it.
It's a really pretty,
my pleasure.
Um,
Tovar.
His book is the mindful carnivores and
it is available everywhere.
It's on Amazon,
printed by Pegasus books and a tow bars
are really,
thanks sir.
I appreciate it,
man.
His lifeline.
Goodnight everybody.
Great.
Okay.